nous entamons ce soir nos travaux sur le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 comme vous le
savez cet exercice représente l'un des
temps forts de notre commission chaque
année
c'est également un moment déterminant
pour l'ensemble de nos concitoyens tant
les mesures que nous serons amenées en
terminer concernent l'amélioration de
leur quotidien nous commençons donc ce
soir par l'audition des ministres mais
les prochaines étapes de nos travaux
seront également marqués par l'audition
le mercredi 5 octobre à 11h du premier
président de la Cour des comptes sur le
rapport relatif à l'application des LFSS
puis nous poursuivrons à partir du lundi
10 octobre à 17h avec l'examen des
articles pour celles et ceux qui ont
connu les législatures précédentes vous
avez sans nul doute pu noter que le
dépôt de ce texte intervient cette année
beaucoup plus tôt que d'habitude et on
peut que s'en réjouir bien sûr comme
j'aime à rendre à César ce qui
appartient à César nous le devons à la
loi organique du 14 mars dernier adopté
à l'initiative de Thomas Meunier je
tenais donc bien sûr à le rappeler
il arrive
voilà juste un mot à ce moment là je
rendais effectivement à ces artères
pathonnêtes à César
désormais le code de la sécurité sociale
prévoit un effet que le projet de loi de
financement de l'année soit déposé sur
le bureau de l'Assemblée nationale au
plus tard le premier mardi d'octobre
jusqu'à lors les anciens s'en
souviennent évidemment il y avait à
peine deux jours pour amender le texte
en commission entre le mercredi soir et
le vendredi soir cette année nous
disposerons donc de 10 jours jusqu'au 6
octobre à 17h c'était donc l'un des
objectifs de la révision de la lolse et
je suis bien sûr certaines que chacun
appréciera ce progrès considérable
cependant la Commission n'a bien sûr pas
attendu le dépôt du texte pour
s'investir pleinement dans ce bel
effetss j'en veux pour preuve le
lancement fin juillet dernier de deux
groupes de travail consacrés à des
sujets au combien d'actualité à savoir
l'accès aux soins et l'autonomie ces
deux entités créent sous l'impulsion de
la rapporteur général madame Rist
réunissant des membres issus des dix
groupes politiques de notre assemblée
ont pour mission d'élaborer des
propositions conjoines qui pourront
ensuite être introduites par voie
d'amendement au PLFSS à l'image de
l'accord qui avait été trouvé au début
de cette législature sur la
déconjugalisation de la hache
nul doute que mes collègues ici présents
soulèveront plusieurs questions bien sûr
sur ces thématiques qui préoccupent bien
sûr la représentation nationale mais
également des millions de nos
concitoyens qui attendent de nous que
nous répondions à ces enjeux majeurs je
ne serai donc pas plus longue je vais
vous passer la parole monsieur les
ministres afin que vous puissiez nous
présenter les principales mesures de ce
pelletfss qui nous permettront de
relever les défis de demain je précise
qu'après vous interventions je donnerai
la parole à Madame la rapporteur général
Stéphanie riste pour trois minutes puis
au rapporteur thématique pour deux
minutes chacun aux orateurs des groupes
pour 4 minutes chacun et enfin aux
autres députés pour d'éventuelles
questions de 2 minutes je vais on me
demande avant la prise de parole des
ministres madame Caroline Fiat vous avez
la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente en
discutant avec nos collègues des autres
commissions j'ai pu m'apercevoir que la
règle des 5 minutes par orateur par
groupe restez de mise dans les autres
commissions lors de la mandature
précédente il arrivait effectivement
qu'on demande lorsque il y avait trop de
monde que les orateurs de groupe fassent
un peu plus courts que 5 minutes mais
l'habitude devient que on est que deux
minutes là on vous remercierait presque
d'en avoir quatre mais savoir si on
pouvait revenir sur la règle des 5
minutes pour les orateurs par groupe je
vous remercie
je pense franchement que nous sommes
nombreux à prendre la parole que 4
minutes ça reste quand même tout à fait
convenable et donc comme ça a été acté
ainsi nous restons sur les quatre
minutes
mais ne vous inquiétez pas vous allez
vous exprimer donc je passe à présent la
parole à Monsieur François Brown
merci merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente chère Fadila catabi madame la
rapporteur général cher Stéphanie rists
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
thématiques mesdames et messieurs les
députés
je suis très heureux de vous retrouver
avec mes collègues ministres
Jean-Christophe combe Gabriel Attal en
cette rentrée parlementaire le PLFSS qui
va nous occuper ce soir et pour les
prochaines semaines constitue un moment
structurant notre politique de santé et
de protection sociale
ce PLFSS est plus qu'un exercice qu'un
exercice budgétaire hors-sol c'est le
mur porteur de notre système de
protection sociale et de ses évolutions
la crise sanitaire nous l'a montré et
nous envoyer encore les conséquences
budgétaires
la sécurité sociale dont je veux saluer
l'engagement des agents au quotidien et
notre patrimoine vivant au service des
Français qui ne cessent de s'adapter
face aux épreuves aux nouveaux enjeux de
et demain je l'espère aux besoins de
santé de nos concitoyens
en tant que premier texte de finance
sociale du second quinquennat ce
plfssent vise à traduire les engagements
pris par le Président de la République
notamment en matière d'accès à la santé
et de prévention à poser une première
pierre s'agissant de la nécessaire
transformation en profondeur de notre
système de santé à nous donner les
moyens de financer nos politiques
prioritaires
il va maintenant faire l'objet d'une
phase parlementaire à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat que j'espère aussi
féconde que possible le gouvernement se
présente face au parlementaire ouvert au
débat j'y donnerai pour ma part toute
mon énergie
je parlais de débat et je veux dire ici
que nos discussions s'engagent alors que
je m'apprête à installer le Conseil
national de la refondation de la santé
lundi prochain depuis Le Mans je vais
aussi être clair le CNR santé ne
s'oppose pas la démocratie parlementaire
au contraire il en est complémentaire
en matière de santé le diagnostic est
très souvent connu il a été porté par
les acteurs notamment parlementaires je
souhaite donc que les travaux que nous
lancerons sur l'ensemble du territoire
permettent aux citoyens aux acteurs de
santé et aux élus de dialoguer pour
trouver des solutions de cours et de
moyens internes pour que chacun
indépendamment de son lieu d'habitation
de sa vulnérabilité ou de son revenu
puisse accéder à la santé dans de bonnes
conditions
en tant que soignant je sais par
ailleurs l'importance du sens dans nos
métiers c'est pourquoi si j'aborde les
débats sans tabou je souhaite que
l'éthique et le principe de
responsabilité collective puisse guider
nos réflexions
reconquête du temps soignant partage des
tâches et des responsabilités entre
professionnels je sais que vous y êtes
très attentif madame la rapporteur
général permanence des soins sujets
fondamental pour beaucoup d'entre vous
dans vos territoires voici certains des
sujets qui seront débattus dans le CNR
santé
le PLFSS sera donc vocation à être
enrichi par les propositions issues du
CNR santé et des parlementaires il doit
aussi se dire comme complémentaire des
négociations conventionnelles qui
s'engagent avec les professionnels de
santé et des initiatives territoriales
auxquelles vous connaissez mon
attachement
ce PLFSS est avant tout un texte
d'investissement et d'engagement pour la
santé des Françaises et des Français
pour cela nous devons passer à la
vitesse supérieure en matière de
prévention nous le savons les gains
d'une politique ambitieuse en matière de
prévention sont considérables pourtant
la France est très en retard comparé à
la moyenne de ses voisins européens
nous voulons désormais donner toute sa
place à la prévention
c'est pourquoi nous proposons de
déployer des rendez-vous de prévention
qui prendront la forme de bilan de santé
aux âges clés de la vie pris en charge à
100%. je souhaite que chacun puisse y
avoir accès sur tous les publics les
plus éloignés je veux donc que nous
mettions toute notre énergie sur l'allé
vert comme nous avons commencé à le
faire pendant la crise
nous proposons aussi d'élargir la
prescription de vaccins ou pharmacien
sage-femme et infirmiers pour
capitaliser sur les engagements de ses
professionnels pendant la crise et
démocratiser l'accès à la vaccination
améliorer la santé sexuelle des jeunes
et la santé des femmes compte aussi
parmi nos premières priorités je propose
donc pour les moins de 26 ans la
création d'un droit au dépistage sans
ordonnance et pris en charge à 100%
Daisy autre que le VIH
le texte prévoit également la délivrance
gratuite de la contraception d'urgence à
toutes les femmes quel que soit leur âge
alors où l'IVG est menacé dans le monde
c'est une avancée forte que nous
assumons
enfin nous poursuivons la lutte contre
le tabagisme et ses dégâts une des
premières causes de décès évitables en
France
investir dans la santé de nos
concitoyens cela suppose également que
chacun d'entre eux puisse y avoir accès
fidèle à mon souhait d'engager une
culture de l'évaluation il nous faudra
prendre un temps de partage sur le bilan
de nos mesures de l'été la ligne est
simple c'est une mesure a fait ses
preuves je souhaite que nous puissions
la pérenniser
s'agissant de la formation comme le
président de la République s'était
engagé ce PLFSS porte la création d'une
quatrième année de médecine générale
pour améliorer la formation des jeunes
médecins et faciliter leur installation
ultérieure nous avons lancé avec ma
collègue Sylvie Retailleau une mission
qui permettra avec l'appui de 4
professionnels de terrain reconnus de
conduire la concertation que requiert un
tel engagement je ne doute pas que les
débats seront riches sur ce sujet mais
je souhaite que cette quatrième année
soit consacrée à la pratique ambulatoire
auprès de maître de stage universitaires
et en priorité dans les zones de la
démographie médicale est soudains
parallèlement nous souhaitons offrir
plus de lisibilité sur notre politique
d'installation afin d'augmenter la
portée en simplifiant le système des
aides à l'installation devenue illisible
mais aussi en créant parallèlement à ce
PLFSS des guichets uniques en lien avec
les élus locaux qui permettront
professionnels d'être mieux accompagnés
dans leur installation en ayant
désormais qu'un scène interlocuteur pour
toutes les aides le Conseil d'État a
choisi de ne pas retenir ses
dispositions estimant qu'elle n'était
pas d'ordre législatif mais je sais
qu'elle ne manquer pas d'animer les
débats
permettent aux Français de se soigner
c'est aussi donner les moyens à nos
hôpitaux de fonctionner ce PLFSS protège
nos hôpitaux contrairement à ce qui a pu
se faire nous ne demanderons aucune
mesure d'économie à l'hôpital pour
laisser le temps de la restructuration
et nous lui donnons les moyens de faire
face au choc financier qu'il subit
maître responsable c'est aussi
travailler sur l'efficacité de nos
dépenses
préserver nos comptes sociaux et mon
collègue Gabriel Attali reviendra
certainement c'est assurer l'avenir de
la couverture sociale et permet demain
de continuer à investir et adapter le
service à nos concitoyens
ce budget de la Sécurité Sociale propose
ainsi des mesures que nous pensons juste
et proportionner afin de préserver la
soutenabilité de notre système social
nous allons ainsi demander un effort de
responsabilité au secteur de la
radiologie en renforçant la transparence
et l'information sur le coût de leurs
équipements matériels et de la biologie
en ouvrant une négociation avec ce
secteur parallèlement à l'engagement
d'une mission pour mieux préparer son
avenir nous travaillerons également avec
les complémentaires santé qui ont leur
place dans notre système de santé nous
partageons des ambitions fortes pour
intensifier la prévention par exemple
nous devons également travailler
ensemble pour leur participation accrue
à l'effort collectif alors que ces
dernières années la part des dépenses
prises en charge par l'assurance maladie
obligatoire n'a cessé de progresser
enfin nous accroîtrons nos efforts de la
dans la lutte contre tous les types
d'abus et de fraude en ne prenant plus
en charge les arrêts de travail prescrit
abusivement par téléconsultation par
exemple ou encore en donnant au
directeur de ces femmes de nouveaux
pouvoirs
ces efforts sont indépassables si l'on
veut maintenir la confiance de nos
concitoyens dans notre sécurité sociale
au final nous avons un nom d'âme
dynamique au service de la santé de nos
concitoyens l'objectif national de
dépenses d'assurance maladie l'ONDAM
n'est pas un chiffre ce n'est jamais que
la traduction de choix politiques que
nous assumons ces deux dernières années
nous avons fait le choix d'un
investissement courageux à la fois pour
préserver l'activité de notre pays et la
santé de nos concitoyens je pense
notamment au soutien financier massif
mobilisé pour répondre à la crise
sanitaire aux investissements durables
du Ségur de la santé et au soutien face
à l'inflation notamment pour les
établissements de santé et
médico-sociaux
avec ce PLFSS nous continuons dans cette
voie exigeante mais nécessaire ainsi
pour 2023 l'ONDAM est proposé un niveau
élevé à plus
3,7%. hors dépenses de crise covid c'est
un effort important que nous sommes
prêts à faire en faveur de la santé des
Français en ville comme à l'hôpital
l'ONDA hospitalier est ainsi un niveau
de plus 4,1% soit un investissement de
plus de 100 milliards d'euros dans les
établissements de santé nous
investissons résolument dans l'hôpital
comme je l'ai dit nous renouvelons aussi
nos exigences en matière d'éthique pour
remettre certaines dernières au cœur de
notre système de santé cela doit
notamment passer par un encadrement plus
exigeant de l'intérim s'agissant des
rémunérations devenus inacceptables
comme des conditions d'exercice sous ce
statut
le défi est grand continue d'investir
tout en maitrisant nos finances sociales
j'assume ce double objectif mais de très
fort comme le président de la République
l'a dit ne se fera pas par des coupes
budgétaires sur le dos de la santé de
nos citoyens
se redressement se fera par un
investissement durable dans nos
priorités de long terme dans la
prévention et la qualité et la
pertinence de notre système de santé
mesdames et messieurs les députés je ne
serai pas plus longs pour laisser du
temps à l'échange ce PLFSS est une
première réponse aux besoins de nos
concitoyens de nos soignants et qui
parient résolument sur la refondation de
notre système de santé je laisse la
parole à mes collègues jean-christophobe
et Gabriel Attal et je me tiens à votre
disposition bien entendu pour répondre à
vos questions merci bien monsieur le
ministre donc la parole est à Monsieur
Jean qui se trouve con ministre des
Solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés avec ce projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale de protection nous tenons les
engagements pris pour les personnes en
situation de handicap nous prenons des
mesures immédiates pour protéger les
familles et les personnes âgées nous
lançons les chantiers structurel du
quinquennat pour préparer l'avenir et
continuer à lutter contre les inégalités
de destin et enfin nous protégeons de
l'inflation les établissements qui
prennent soin de nos concitoyens âgés et
de nos concitoyens en situation de
handicap
concernant l'enfance et les familles
d'abord en proposant une augmentation de
1,6 milliards d'euros un milliard 600
millions d'euros nous faisons clairement
le choix de soutenir les familles et
notamment les plus fragiles avec ce
PLFSS nous avons deux objectifs
contribuer à la société du plein emploi
en développant l'accès à un mode
d'accueil pour les jeunes enfants et
continuer à lutter contre les inégalités
à la racine en intervenant dès la petite
enfance et en soutenant les familles les
plus fragiles nous posons ainsi la
première pierre du service public de la
petite enfance engagement de campagne du
président de la République qui s'inscrit
dans la droite ligne de ce qui a été
fait avec les 1000 premiers jours
concrètement nous proposons de réformer
le complément mode de garde en faisant
deux choses d'abord en réduisant le
barème pour permettre aux familles qui
n'ont pas de place en crèche de pouvoir
faire garder leurs enfants au même coup
par une assistante maternelle ou une
garde à domicile c'est une réponse qui
va se traduire par des économies de
plusieurs centaines d'euros par an pour
les familles ensuite nous rallongeons
son bénéfice au-delà de 6 ans et jusqu'à
l'entrée au collège pour les familles
monoparentales qui ne peuvent pas
bénéficier du relais de l'autre parent
cette réforme du complément mode de
garde s'ajoute au lancement de la
trajectoire qui nous permettra de créer
200000 places de garde manquantes d'ici
à 2030 il y a l'augmentation de 50% du
montant de la pension alimentaire
minimale qui passera ainsi c'est à
location de soutien familiale de 123 à
185 euros par mois et par enfant vous le
savez les familles monoparentales à 80 %
des femmes ont longtemps été les oubliés
des politiques publiques alors même que
plus de 30% d'entre elles vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté
dans la droite ligne des réformes
lancées sous le précédent quinquennat
notamment avec la mise en place du
service public de versement des pensions
alimentaires nous continuons ainsi à
soutenir et à protéger ces mères et
souvent isoler pour les aider à élever
leurs enfants dans de bonnes conditions
toutes ces mesures s'inscrivent dans la
création du grand service public
universel de la petite enfance qui sera
le fil rouge tout au long de ce
quinquennat il permettra d'améliorer
l'accès à l'emploi le développement des
enfants l'égalité des femmes et des
hommes et le soutien aux familles les
plus fragiles soutenir les familles
c'est le meilleur investissement social
notamment quand cela permet aux parents
de travailler et aux enfants de ne pas
être livrés à eux-mêmes en ce qui
concerne les personnes âgées notre
objectif c'est d'abord de restaurer la
confiance dans les EHPAD et d'accélérer
sur le domicile parce qu'une immense
majorité des Français souhaite vivre
pouvoir vieillir à domicile
restaurer la confiance dans les EHPAD
c'est le contrôle et la sanction
évidemment nous augmentons les moyens
humains pour réussir le plan de 7500
contrôles en deux ans que nous avons
annoncé et nous améliorons le circuit
des signalements des maltraitances et
nous organisons la récupération des
financements publics s'il s'avère qu'ils
ont été détournés de leur objet mais
restaurer la confiance dans les EHPAD
c'est aussi et surtout soutenir les
professionnels formidables qui
travaillent
donc nous allons financer le recrutement
de 50 000 soignants dans les prochaines
années la question des ressources
humaines est absolument clé et comme le
savent les professionnels du secteur ce
n'est pas une question de rémunération
ce n'est pas qu'une question de
rémunération il faut tout regarder et le
faire tout ensemble la formation le
management les parcours professionnels
la reconnaissance la crise de sens est
profonde et cet ensemble que nous la
surmonterons accélérer sur le domicile
ensuite c'est aider les Français à
adapter leur logement et développer les
services à domicile développer les
services à domicile c'est déjà faire en
sorte qu'il y en ait plus nous finançons
ici la création de nouvelles places de
services de soins infirmiers à domicile
l'objectif étant d'en augmenter le
nombre chaque année pour en avoir 25000
places de plus en 2030 soit une
augmentation de l'offre de près de 20%
se faire en sorte aussi que les services
soient financièrement accessibles et de
qualité c'est ce que nous soutenons avec
une tarification qui prenne mieux en
compte les profils des bénéficiaires et
un tarif plancher qui sera revalorisé
pour tenir compte de l'inflation
c'est faire en sorte aussi que l'offre
de services soit plus visible pour les
usagers en 2022 on avait rassemblé tous
les sadsiades et ce passage et ce
passage dans une catégorie unique de
services autonomie l'objectif est de
simplifier le parcours en mettant à leur
disposition un guichet unique qui leur
propose une réponse en aide et ou en
soins qui soient graduée et adapté à
leurs besoins en 2023 on accélère on
incitant financièrement les services à
dispenser à la fois des activités
d'accompagnement d'aide et de soins et
puis c'est surtout faire en sorte que
l'organisation des services d'aide à
domicile soit plus adaptées pour les
professionnels comme pour les personnes
qui en bénéficient nous allons donc
tenir l'engagement du président de la
République de permettre aux aides à
domicile de passer plus de temps auprès
des personnes qu'ils accompagnent trop
souvent ils ont tout juste le temps de
faire des gestes élémentaires pour
assurer le lever le coucher la toilette
le repas nous ajouterons donc avec les
départements avec lesquels nous allons
ouvrir une
deux heures de présence supplémentaires
chaque semaine auprès des 780 000
personnes qui bénéficient de
l'allocation personnalisée d'autonomie à
domicile deux heures dédiées à la
convivialité et à la prévention deux
heures qui permettront aussi d'améliorer
les conditions de travail des
professionnels qui trop souvent
subissent des temps partiels ou du
travail de fractionné
accéléré sur le domicile c'est soutenir
le développement de l'habitat inclusif
comme une alternative intermédiaire les
maisons de répit pour les aidants mais
aussi poursuivre la transformation des
EHPAD l'objectif est qu'il soit en
situation d'accueillir des personnes
moins autonomes et qu'ils soient un
centre de ressources territoriale pour
l'accompagnement des autres à domicile
par exemple en proposant un
accompagnement hors les murs pour les
personnes qui auraient besoin d'un
soutien plus intensif et ne pouvant
épousant pardon rester chez elle enfin
vieillir à domicile c'est avoir un
logement adapté nous sommes en train de
faire un gros travail de simplification
et d'harmonisation des aides existantes
pour pouvoir créer
le dispositif sera pleinement
opérationnel au tout début de l'année
2024 et il permettra à au moins 400 000
foyers d'adapter leurs logements d'ici
2027 toutes ces mesures s'inscrivent
dans la construction de la 5e branche de
la sécurité sociale qu'il est là qui est
l'un des piliers du Bien Vieillir ce
chantier que le Président de la
République a porté dans le Conseil
national de la refondation sera notre
fil rouge tout au long du quinquennat
nous devons répondre à l'urgence des
besoins et anticiper plus en 2035 un
quart de la population aura plus de 65
ans sur le handicap le PLFSS tient
rigoureusement les engagements
financiers qui ont été pris pour
déployer les actions que nous avons
défini avec l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés sur la détection précoce et
sur un meilleur accompagnement du
polyhandicap des troubles du spectre
autistique ou des personnes handicapées
vieillissantes par ailleurs c'est une
priorité du président de la République
nous allons davantage développer les
relations entre l'école et
l'accompagnement médic social pour
réussir l'acte 2 de l'école inclusive
nous souhaitons nous inscrire dans
l'habitude de concertation que nous
avons avec les acteurs du handicap et la
prochaine Conférence nationale du
handicap sera l'occasion de renouveler
les objectifs pour les années à venir
beaucoup a été fait mais à chaque
situation sans solution chaque situation
sans solution pardon est un drame et à
chaque présence
et chaque présence d'un enfant en
situation de handicap dans une classe
une richesse pour tout le monde enfin
sur l'inflation ces mesures de moyens et
long terme s'inscrivent dans un contexte
d'urgence et ce PLFSS est aussi des
aussi des mesures anti-inflation que
nous prenons pour soutenir les
établissements médico-sociaux parce
qu'ils prennent soin de nos concitoyens
âgés et de nos concitoyens en situation
de handicap ce sont des établissements
essentiels qui reposent sur des
professionnels exceptionnels et qui font
déjà face à de gros problèmes de
recrutement concrètement pour tous les
établissements nous augmentons les
salaires en augmentant le point de la
fonction publique et nous finançons une
augmentation équivalente dans les autres
établissements nous compensons l'impact
de l'inflation sur les charges non
salariales des établissements et enfin
nous allons étendre le gel des tarifs
sur l'énergie à tous les EHPAD chacun
doit prendre ses responsabilités et
comme vous le voyez le gouvernement est
au rendez-vous
merci bien monsieur le ministre et la
parole est à Monsieur gadri Gabriel
Attal pardon ministre délégué auprès du
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique chargée des comptes publics
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les députés je vais commencer par un
point qui ne se fait pas vraiment
traditionnellement mais je voudrais
remarquer remercier celles et ceux qui
sont derrière nous qui sont celles et
ceux qui ont contribué à l'élaboration
de ce texte vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente calendrier a été avancé par
rapport aux années précédentes ce qui
fait que pour la première fois nous
avons aujourd'hui présenté le même jour
un PLF un plfs une loi de programmation
des finances publiques ce qui veut dire
que vous avez des centaines de femmes et
d'hommes dans l'administration qui ont
travaillé parfois jour et nuit ces
dernières semaines et cet été pour ces
textes je tiens à les remercier il y a
la Direction de la Sécurité sociale la
direction de la cohésion sociale et
évidemment les administrations de Bercy
notamment la direction du budget et
d'ailleurs tous les textes qui ont été
présentés aujourd'hui les trois textes
présentés aujourd'hui ont une cohérence
ils vise à nous permettre de relever les
défis majeurs qui sont devant nous et
notre conviction c'est que ces défis
nous pouvons les relever ensemble je
suis ministre des comptes publics et
donc je suis aussi le ministre des
comptes sociaux et je le dis souvent les
choix budgétaires budgétaires traduisent
des choix politiques c'est pourquoi ce
PLFSS 2023 est d'abord un PLFSS de
confiance confiance en tous les acteurs
de notre système social des soignants de
l'hôpital public jusqu'aux personnel de
la petite enfance des professionnels de
santé en ville au personnel de
l'autonomie chacun détient une part de
la solution voilà pourquoi londam
progressera à un niveau historique de
3,7% hors covid j'insiste sur ce point
en 2023 l'ONDAM progressera 50% plus
vite qu'au cours de la décennie 2010
c'est le signe qu'après le Ségur de la
santé nous poursuivons les forts
financiers au profit de la santé secteur
prioritaire pour les Français et donc
pour le gouvernement pour la dame
hospitalier le taux d'évolution
s'élèvera à 4,1% en 2023 c'est deux fois
plus qu'au cours de la décennie 2010 où
il était de 2% en moyenne ces chiffres
sont clairs notre gouvernement et notre
majorité ont investi et vont continuer à
investir massivement pour notre hôpital
public
car nos choix sont cohérents en 2017
l'ONDAM s'élevait au total à 190,7
milliards d'euros en 2023 il s'élèvera à
244,1 milliard d'euros c'est 53
milliards d'euros de plus investi dans
notre système de santé depuis 2017 nous
avons mis fin au baisse de tarif
hospitaliers développés le 100% santé
supprimer le numerus clausus soutenu le
secteur de l'aide à domicile et nos
EHPAD et nous allons continuer cet
effort parce que les Français sont
attachés à notre modèle social et que
nous voulons le défendre mais tout cela
je le dis n'est possible que si nous
continuons à donner la priorité au
travail et à la production les
cotisations sociales qui demeurent le
socle de financement de notre sécurité
sociale vont progresser de 390,7
milliards en 2022 à
407,2 milliards en 2023 nous devons
d'abord cette progression aux créations
d'emplois 319 000 sont prévus en 2022
200 000 ont déjà a été réalisé au
premier semestre et 117
000 supplémentaires sont attendus en
2023 au total sur la période 2020-2023
et ce malgré la crise nous devrions
avoir créé 1,2 millions d'emplois alors
n'oublions jamais au moment où j'entends
certains réinterroger la pertinence
d'une réforme des retraites que le
travail et le volume global du travail
dans notre pays et ce qui permet à notre
système social d'être financé et de
tenir voilà pourquoi ce PLFSS est aussi
un message de responsabilité parce que
les besoins sont immenses nous ne devons
pas ménager nos efforts pour trouver
toutes les marges déficiences et oui
pour réaliser des économies là où elles
sont pertinentes faire de la politique
c'est faire des choix c'est pourquoi
nous assumons de demander des efforts à
certains secteurs qui bénéficient de
niveau élevé de rentabilité et peuvent
contribuer à l'effort commun il ne
s'agit de stigmatiser personne
de ne considérer aucune aucun profit
comme indu mais il s'agit de dire que là
où nous pouvons faire des efforts nous
devons faire des efforts si nous voulons
permettre à notre système de tenir ainsi
les laboratoires de biologie qui ont
réalisé un chiffre d'affaires de 7,3
milliards d'euros au titre des tests
covid en 2020 et 2021 et bénéficient
déjà avant la crise d'un taux de
rentabilité élevé alors que 70% de leur
activité est solvabilité par l'Assurance
Maladie feront un effort ce PLFSS
prévoit que la CNAM négociera une baisse
de prix avec le secteur pour au moins
250 millions d'euros en 2023 c'est aussi
le cas de l'imagerie un secteur qui
représente près de 5 milliards de
dépenses et où nous pouvons encore mieux
lutter contre limiter les examens
redondants inappropriés ou inutiles nous
demanderons donc à ce secteur de
négocier avec la CNAM un nouveau
protocole pour juguler la dépense de 150
millions d'euros en 2023
c'est enfin le cas des organismes
complémentaires dont la part dans le
financement des dépenses de santé baisse
tendentiellement il y a 10 ans elle
finançait 15,5% quand elles ne financait
plus que 12,9% des dépenses en 2021 nous
devons donc réfléchir à injuste partage
de l'effort avec la sécurité sociale et
mon collègue François Braun a ouvert des
concertations en ce sens ces efforts
nous ne les demandons pas par plaisir de
faire des économies nous les demandons
parce qu'ils sont indispensables pour
dégager des marges de manoeuvre
budgétaire et investir au premier chef à
l'hôpital c'est aussi la condition pour
garantir la soutenabilité et la
résilience des comptes sociaux à un
moment auprès domine l'incertitude
économique et alors que nos taux
d'intérêt remontent je le rappelle la
parenthèse de l'argent gratuit c'est
refermée notre dette nous coûte cette
année 18 milliards de plus que prévu
c'est deux fois le budget du ministère
de la Justice et si nous continuons
ainsi si nous ne présentons pas c'est ce
que nous faisons avec votre
programmation et ce PLFSS et ce PLF une
trajectoire soutenable de nos dépenses
publiques nous nous exposons à des taux
qui continuent à monter et à la fin à
nous retrouver privés de marge de
manœuvre budgétaire pour investir là où
il le faut pour les Français chacun ici
le saigne il n'y a pas de modèle social
pérenne si celui-ci est financé à crédit
le retour à l'équilibre de nos comptes
sociaux reste donc un impératif pour
toutes celles et ceux qui sont attachées
à sa pérennité ce PLFSS est enfin un
message de fermeté fermeté à l'égard de
toutes celles et de tous ceux qui en
fraudant ou en abusant le système
abîme l'adhésion des Français à notre
modèle social la lutte contre la fraude
est donc aussi au cœur de ce PLFSS et
nous y portons des mesures ambitieuses
des pouvoirs de cyber enquête seront
confiés au contrôleur des caisses de
sécurité sociale pour mieux repérer et
réprimer les fraudes à en jeu notamment
par exemple le travail dissimulé
des facultés de déconventionnement
seront étendues à tous les
professionnels de santé en cas de fraude
majeur des échanges d'information seront
renforcés notamment entre les greffiers
des tribunaux de commerce et les caisses
de sécurité sociale là aussi pour mieux
lutter contre le travail informel
enfin il sera mis fin aux arrêts maladie
prescrits en téléconsultation à
l'exception du médecin traitant ou d'un
médecin déjà consulté au cours des 12
derniers mois je m'arrête un instant
madame la Présidente sur cette mesure
qui a été aprement commentée depuis que
j'en ai fait l'annonce hier je veux
redire qu'il ne s'agit pas de remettre
en cause le remboursement des
téléconsultation elle continueront
toutes à être remboursées il ne s'agit
pas non plus de remettre en cause le
système le principe des arrêts maladie
dans notre pays évidemment il s'agit de
dire qu'il y a des abus et que oui il y
a dans notre pays des personnes qui
peuvent enchaîner des téléconsultations
avec des médecins jusqu'à en trouver un
qui acceptera de leur délivrer un arrêt
maladie parfois un peu complaisant
et oui c'est la réalité de dire que pour
les arrêts maladie qui sont délivrés en
téléconsultation par un médecin qui
n'est pas le médecin traitant deux fois
plus de ces arrêts maladie que les
autres arrêts maladie ne donne lieu
ensuite à aucune prescription de
médicaments de soins ou autre
si on accepte pas de regarder en face
les abus et de chercher à y répondre
nous s'approns durablement la confiance
de nos concitoyens dans notre modèle
social qui ne supporte plus de financer
des abus ou des fraudes donc j'assume et
nous assumons cette mesure importante
pour lutter contre un certain nombre
d'abus et nous en gérichirons encore en
débat cette arsenal de lutte contre la
fraude toutes vos propositions je le dis
seront utiles et je vous annonce d'ores
et déjà que le gouvernement déposera un
amendement pour que soit désormais
facturé au fraudeur des frais de gestion
en plus du recouvrement des sommes
indues parce que les Français n'en
peuvent plus de payer pour ceux qui
fraudent et y compris pour les
fonctionnaires qui sont amenés à devoir
contrôler repérer et sanctionner les
fraudes
et permettez-moi d'insister sur un point
je ne pose pas ici lutte contre la
fraude fiscale et lutte contre la fraude
sociale l'une comme l'autre a des degrés
certes divers mine l'esprit de civisme
dans notre pays l'une comme l'autre
doivent être combattues sans relâche et
c'est le Ministre des comptes publics
qui vous le dit merci cet été infligé
une amende à McDonald's d'un milliard
300 millions d'euros pour optimisation
fiscale l'an dernier les droits demandés
pour des fraudes fiscales dans notre
pays ont atteint un niveau record
historique 13 milliards d'euros cette
année mon ministère a transmis à la
justice trois fois plus de dossiers et
de fraude fiscale que les années
précédentes nous nous attaquons à toutes
les fraudes parce qu'elles minent le
pacte républicain et notre modèle social
alors pour les débats qui nous attendent
j'appelle évidemment à contribution
toutes les bonnes volontés de votre
commission je sais bien sûr pouvoir
compter sur l'ensemble des composantes
de la majorité présidentielle mais que
vous soyez de droite ou de gauche député
du Nord ou du Sud de l'Est ou de l'Ouest
chacune et chacun d'entre vous a
évidemment un rôle à jouer dans la
refondation de notre système social au
fond vous êtes membre de cette
commission parce que chacun d'entre vous
souhaite un système plus simple plus
efficace plus juste alors faisons
ensemble deux ce PLFSS un texte utile
aux Français mesdames et messieurs à une
époque de grande bascule une époque où
le fracas de la guerre revient en Europe
ou menace le défi climatique et un
risque d'effondrement de la biodiversité
à une époque où même l'adhésion à notre
modèle social et une démocratique menace
de céder nous avons chacune et chacun
d'entre nous une responsabilité immense
au-delà de nos clivages légitimes
sachant bâtir avec confiance
responsabilité et fermeté un PLFSS qui
sera l'une des briques d'un pays plus
unis et plus solidaire je vous remercie
merci bien monsieur le ministre sur ce
je vais passer la parole à Stéphanie
risque notre rapporteur général qui
supplait également Cyril Isaki
rapporteur thématique pour la branche
vieillesse et donc ça vous fait 5
minutes madame la rapporteur général
trois plus deux attendez merci madame la
Présidente
messieurs les ministre je vous remercie
pour la présentation que vous avez fait
du premier projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale de la 16e
législature s'agissant de l'évolution
budgétaire tout d'abord je me réjouis
que les régimes de base de la sécurité
sociale poursuivent leur trajectoire
rapide de rétablissement des comptes
puisque le déficit passe de 37,3
milliards en 2020 19,2 milliards en 2022
et atteindrait en 2023 7,6 milliards
d'euros puis voilà la preuve que la
stratégie du maintien de nos concitoyens
en emploi par une intervention massive
de la sécurité sociale a largement porté
ses fruits pour autant on regarde des
prévisions contrastées en fonction des
branches et notamment de la dégradation
rapide et massive des contes d'assurance
vieillesse notre devoir est de
poursuivre le rétablissement des comptes
si nous tenons à notre modèle je saisis
l'opportunité de cette prise de parole
pour saluer mon prédécesseur Thomas
Meunier qui grâce à sa réforme organique
nous permet de disposer d'un délai
d'examen de texte plus confortable
s'agissant du contenu du PLFSS je me
félicite pour mon premier exercice en
tant que rapporteur général que les
chantiers annoncés par le Président de
la République comme par notre majorité
au cours de la campagne soit d'ores et
déjà inscrit dans ce texte je pense
notamment au rendez-vous de prévention
aux âges clés de la vie je salue aussi
la prise en charge intégrale par
l'Assurance Maladie de la contraception
d'urgence ainsi que la prise en charge
des dépistages sans ordonnance des
infections sexuellement transmissibles
j'ai par ailleurs plusieurs autres
chantiers qui me tiennent à cœur et sur
lesquels je pense que nous pourrions
avancer en effet des contacts réguliers
avec les acteurs du soin dans les
territoires je retire la conviction que
le partage d'activités entre médecins et
professionnels de santé est
indispensable pour améliorer l'accès aux
des Français c'est d'ailleurs ce que
nous faisons avec ce PLFSS qui va
élargir la faculté de prescrire des
vaccins aux pharmaciens infirmiers à ce
titre je pense que nous pourrions
accélérer et permettre l'accès direct
aux infirmiers en pratique avancées je
suis aussi convaincu que nous pouvons
étendre les prérogatives des infirmiers
diplômés d'État à la signature de
certificat de décès à la prescription
d'arrêt de travail de très courte durée
dans le cadre de soins coordonnés avec
les médecins monsieur le ministre quel a
l'intention du gouvernement sur ces
sujets qui je le crois pourront
permettre de libérer du temps médical et
valoriser les compétences de l'ensemble
des professionnels de santé je pense
également que nous devons agir de
manière urgente et forte pour améliorer
la santé des jeunes médecins les
statistiques sur leur état de santé
doivent nous alerter seriez-vous prêt
monsieur le ministre de la Santé à
prévoir des moyens dédiés pour assurer
le suivi médical et psychologique des
internes indépendamment de leur lieu de
stage je souhaite enfin souligner les
forces fait en soutien à l'autonomie
avec 1,5 milliards de financement
supplémentaire consacré au secteur
médico-social j'aurais monsieur le
ministre deux questions pensez-vous
faire évoluer le modèle de financement
des dispositifs d'appui à la
coordination dans certains territoires
et connaître l'intention du gouvernement
sur l'opportunité de laisser la
possibilité aux médecins coordonnateur
de devenir le médecin traitant des
résidents des EHPAD
madame la Présidente je poursuis avec
l'intervention de Cyril Isaki
de la branche vieillesse qui ne peut
être présent aujourd'hui
je ne peux que revenir sur les enjeux
financiers de notre système de retraite
qui a agité tant de débat au cours des
dernières semaines après le rapport du
Conseil d'orientation des retraites le
15 septembre dernier et l'avis du comité
de suivi des retraites du 22 la
trajectoire financière que présente les
annexes au plfs pour 2023 ne font que
confirmer l'ampleur du déficit de la
branche vieillesse bien au-delà des
craintes que nous pouvions avoir
jusqu'ici en effet alors que le déficit
de la branche vieillesse pour l'ensemble
des régimes obligatoires de base s'élevé
à 8,5 milliards d'euros en 2025 il est
désormais estimé à 15,9 milliards
d'euros en 2026 cela représente un peu
plus de trois fois le déficit constaté
en 2020 au pire moment la crise
sanitaire et économique c'est absolument
considérable messieurs les ministres
quels sont les principaux facteurs qui
expliquent l'ampleur de cette
dégradation
force est de constater par ailleurs que
le niveau des dépenses lui-même a connu
à court terme une évolution majeure
alors que nous approuvions dans la
précédente loi de financement un
objectif de dépenses des régimes
obligatoires de base pour l'assurance
vieillesse à hauteur de
256,6 milliards d'euros cet objectif est
porté pour 2023 à 273,3 milliards
d'euros cette augmentation de 17
milliards qui représente une hausse
d'environ 7% des dépenses
s'explique-t-elle principalement par les
prévisions de l'impact de l'inflation
sur les dépenses ou existe-t-il d'autres
facteurs je vous remercie merci bien
Madame la rapporteur général très
concise je passe à présent la parole à
Annie Vidal qui supplait Caroline
janvier rapporteur thématique pour la
branche autonomie pour deux minutes
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres je me fais donc porte-parole
de ma collègue Caroline janvier qui se
réjouit que le gouvernement ait choisi
d'engager de nouvelles mesures
ambitieuses en faveur du soutien à
l'autonomie dans le cadre de ce premier
plfs de la législature force est de
constater que PLFSS après PLFSS la
branche autonomie prend forme et grandi
l'objectif de dépenses pour 2023 fixé à
37,3 milliards d'euros est un
augmentation de près de 2 milliards
d'euros par rapport à l'objectif
rectifié pour demain 2022 soit une
hausse de plus de 5 % c'est considérable
ces chiffres sont la traduction de
plusieurs mesures tangibles le projet de
loi que vous présentez aujourd'hui pose
tout d'abord les premiers jalons du plan
de recrutement d'environ 50 000
aide-soignantes et infirmières en EHPAD
dans les cinq prochaines années nous ne
pouvons que saluer la concrétisation de
cet engagement du Président de la
République qui constitue une première
réponse à la préoccupante pénurie de
personnel constaté dans de nombreux
établissements le présent projette loi
permet ainsi de créer 3000 postes
supplémentaires pour un coût d'environ
172 millions d'euros au-delà de ce va ce
plan de recrutement l'enjeu de
l'attractivité des filières de
l'accompagnement social
médico-social et majeur nous nous devons
d'être à la hauteur en poursuivant nos
efforts en faveur de la valorisation des
métiers le projet de loi comporte
ensuite une réforme d'ampleur visant à
prévenir les abus et des rides dans la
gestion financière des EHPAD privés
commerciaux dans le cadre d'une mission
flash consacrée à ce sujet à la suite
des révélations de l'affaire Europa ma
collègue Caroline janvier et ses
collègues Janine dubier et Pierre
d'arriville ont fait le constat au
printemps dernier d'un secteur de plus
en plus financiarisé et de nombreuses
angles morts dans le contrôle par l'état
de l'utilisation des deniers publics
reprenant un certain nombre de leurs
préconisations l'article 32 renforce les
exigences de transparence s'appliquant à
la gestion comptable et financière des
EHPAD et dotent les autorités publiques
de prérogatives renforcée en matière de
contrôle et de sanctions de ces
établissements
le présent projet doit comporte en outre
plusieurs mesures je vais interrompre
l'âge elle avait été très généreuse dans
son intervention je suis désolé de ne
pouvoir aller au bout je conclurai en
disant que nous nous devons d'être à la
hauteur des enjeux de du défi du
vieillissement de la population merci
bien Madame la Députée la parole est à
présent pour à Paul Christophe pardon
rapporteur thématique pour la branche
famille deux minutes également monsieur
le député merci même la présidente
messieurs les ministres madame la
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
je voudrais commencer par souligner
l'importance des moyens dédiés à la
branche famille en est augmentation par
rapport à l'année 2022 vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le ministre cela se
comporte principalement deux mesures
d'importance dans le champ de la famille
en premier lieu la réforme du complément
de libre choix du mode de garde le CMG
premier jalon du projet du service
public d'accueil de la petite enfance
annoncé par le président de la
République en proposant une réforme du
calcul du CMG l’article 36 permet en
effet de palier une profonde injustice
l'inégalité d'accès au mode de garde en
fonction des revenus des familles cet
article comprend par ailleurs des
dispositions visant à répondre à la
situation particulière des familles
monoparentales dont l'accompagnement
constitue une priorité depuis le
précédent quinquennat le CMG ainsi sur
un site en dû aux enfants âgés de 6 à 12
ans pour ses familles il est enfin prévu
de permettre le partage entre les deux
parents du CMG emploi direct en cas de
garde alternée de l'enfant afin de
s'adapter au mieux à la situation et la
singularité de chaque famille les
premières auditions fait apparaître une
interrogation sur le fait que la
rémunération horaire puisse ne pas
excéder à un plafond fixé par décret
avec le besoin de voir prise en compte
les tarifs majorés pour garde atypique
ou en lien avec une situation de
handicap monsieur le ministre je
souhaite éclairer sur ce point la
deuxième mesure porte sur la
simplification et la modernisation du
versement des indemnités prévues pour
l'arrivée d'un enfant l'article 37 de ce
texte permet en effet d'assurer une
garantie financière pour les parents en
systématisant la subrogation par
l'employeur des indemnités journalières
pour les congés
je reviens maintenant au contenu du pfss
pour 2023 je tiens à saluer un certain
nombre de mesures qui figure dans le
texte je citerai notamment les crédits
supplémentaires pour les maisons de
retraite afin de faire face à
l'inflation et surtout le bouclier
tarifaire sur le prix d'énergie comme
pour les particuliers je citerai
également le prolongement jusqu'au 1er
janvier 2024 du dispositif d'exonération
lié à l'emploi de travailleurs
occasionnels demandeurs d'emploi qui
permet de soutenir le secteur agricole
cela étant dit je conseille concentrerai
cette intervention sur la branche
accident du travail et maladie
professionnelle pour laquelle je suis
rapporteur au titre de l'opposition et
dont les objectifs de dépenses pour
l'ensemble des régimes obligatoires de
base sont fixés pour 2023 à 14,8
milliards d'euros en 2021 le solde de la
branche ATMP redevenu positif à hauteur
de 1,3 milliards d'euros ce sol devra
encore s'améliorer cette année pour
atteindre 2 milliards d'euros et même
2,2 milliards d'euros l'année prochaine
et comme pour faire bien il faut voir
loin paraît-il je vous propose de nous
projeter jusqu'en 2026 comme nous liens
invite l'annexe B dont du PLFSS puisque
à cet horizon le sol de la branche
devrait connaître un excédent de plus de
3 milliards d'euros s'agissant des
mesures contenues dans le texte je tiens
à saluer l'amélioration de la réparation
des accidents du travail et des maladies
professionnelles dénon salariés
agricoles plus réactif des
collaborateurs et des aidants familiaux
qui est prévu à l'article 40 du texte
avant de laisser la parole à mes
collègues je souhaiterais interroger le
ministre de la Santé de l'appréhension
sur le fonctionnement de la médecine du
travail j'ai pu constater dans mon
département que les rendez-vous
n'étaient plus assurés périodiquement
faute de professionnelle de santé de
moyens ce qui peut fragiliser l'ambition
forte de prévention monsieur le ministre
de la santé et de la prévention
j'aimerais connaître l'évolution au
niveau national de l'activité de la
médecine du travail quels sont les
tendances que vous avez pu observer
comment la réforme que nous avons
adoptée l'an dernier pour renforcer la
prévention en santé au travail est mise
en oeuvre merci bien la parole à présent
est à Madame Prisca theveno au titre de
la délégation des droits des femmes pour
deux minutes
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres madame la rapporteur général
tout d'abord je tiens à vous remercier
madame la Présidente au nom de la
délégation droit des femmes d'avoir
permis que celle-ci écrimait ici au
travers moi la voix des femmes si
beaucoup a été fait au cours du
précédent quinquennat il reste encore à
faire notamment sur le sujet de la santé
des femmes il en effet essentiel que
nous considérions la santé des femmes de
bout en bout de l'adolescence à la
seigneurité ce début de législature et
ce premier PLFSS sont ainsi l'occasion
de poser la première pierre d'une
véritable stratégie nationale du
parcours de la santé des femmes
si ce projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 ne pouvait ni
Naver vocation à régler l'ensemble des
sujets liés à la santé des femmes nous
avons toutefois pu relever dans ce texte
des avancées que nous pensons pertinents
de pouvoir spécifier sur l'article 17
les consultations de prévention santé
tout d'abord il est essentiel que ce
suivi à l'âge adulte s'inscrivent dans
la continuité des vins rendez-vous de
santé obligatoire du mineur il
conviendra donc sans doute de réfléchir
à une mise en cohérence afin de les
rendre parfaitement lisibles et
complémentaires en outre et surtout le
contenu des visites devrait être
spécifié adapté au corps féminin et
communiquer clairement aux
professionnels de façon à ce qu'il
réponde de façon globale aux besoins des
corps des femmes qui sont particuliers
enfin est plus globalement je tiens
vraiment à le souligner ici des
campagnes de communication et
d'informations doivent absolument être
lancées afin que ces mesures soient
connues de leur bénéficiaire et une
réelle efficacité sur l'article 19 la
gratuité de la contraception d'urgence
pour toutes les femmes sur ce point la
délégation droit des femmes sera
particulièrement attentive au modalités
de garantie de la confidentialité de
cette démarche en particulier pour les
jeunes majeurs encore ayant droit de
leurs parents c'est ici un point
d'alerte nous nous devons de garantir la
confidentialité des jeunes majeurs
vis-à-vis de leurs parents de la même
manière que pour les mineurs ainsi la
procédure permettant aux pharmaciens de
renseigner un NIR anonyme serait de ce
point de vue tout à fait adapté
enfin sur un autre sujet important je
suis désolé madame la députée je
pourrais du coup échanger plus tard sur
l'endométriose merci bien c'est un vrai
sujet vous avez raison vous avez dit
l'essentiel merci merci bien Madame la
député je vais passer à présent aux
orateurs de groupe
madame Astrid panotion Bouvet pour
renaissance pour 4 minutes
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres madame la rapporteur général
un projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale traduit des objectifs
politiques et sa trajectoire chiffrée en
matière sanitaire et sociale pour
l'année à venir et ce PLFSS pour 2023
mais en lumière trois grandes priorités
politiques du gouvernement au service
des Français à tous les âges de leur vie
il s'agit de la prévention et l'accès
aux soins de la construction d'un
nouveau service public pour les jeunes
enfants et les familles et la volonté de
bien vieillir en particulier de bien
vieillir chez soi ce PLFSS matérialise
également à un effort financier
considérable dans un contexte de très
forte inflation pour investir dans la
modernisation du système de santé et
valoriser les professionnels qui le font
vivre tout en tenant le cap du
redressement des comptes sociaux ça a
été rappelé revenons sur la grande
première priorité de ce PLFSS celle de
la prévention et l'accès aux soins trop
longtemps nous avons collectivement fait
le choix du curatif au du préventif et
ce PLFSS marque l'entrée dans une
véritable
ère de la prévention avec notamment la
mise en place de bilan de santé
intégralement pris en charge par
l'assurance maladie aux âges charnières
de la vie d'autres mesures en
particulier pour les femmes ont été
rappelées par ma collègue Prisca tvno
pour être pleinement efficace et éviter
les billets individuels cette prévention
devra également à l'avenir être
collective et non plus simplement
personnel et s'appuyer pour cela sur une
diversité d'acteurs comme ceux de la
Protection Maternelle et Infantile la
protection de l'enfance la médecine
scolaire la médecine du travail ou
encore les associations et pas
simplement ceux de la santé
face à la problématique des déserts
médicaux et des inégalités territoriales
qui se traduisent d'ailleurs par des
disparités régionales en matière
d'espérance de vie telle qu'elles ont
été rappelées par la récente étude de
l'adresse sur l'état de santé des
Français ce PLFSS prévoit aussi de
reconquérir du temps médical dans tous
les territoires en simplifiant en
renforçant la coordination de politique
d'installation en rénovant la vie
conventionnelle entre professionnels de
santé assurance maladie ou en
introduisant une quatrième année
d'internat pour les médecins
généralistes il sera intéressant
monsieur le ministre de savoir comment
ce PLFSS pourra s'enrichir également des
discussions du CNR et du groupe de
travail parlementaire transpartisans sur
les déserts médicaux
je ne reviendrai pas sur
l'accompagnement des jeunes enfants et
des familles qui est une autre priorité
de ce texte avec de grandes avancées je
terminerai ici sur le la volonté de bien
vieillir de mieux vieillir en France ce
PLFSS pour 2023 prévoit la plus forte
augmentation de l'objectif de dépenses
en faveur des personnes en situation de
handicap et cette augmentation est la
plus importante que l'augmentation
moyenne de tous les autres
sous-objectifs pour obtenir mieux en
compte notamment du polyhandicap en ce
qui concerne les EHPAD on prévoit
également d'augmenter le temps de
présence et d'encadrement des soignants
auprès des résidents en lançant enfin se
recrutement de plan de recrutement de 50
000 infirmiers aide-soignants avec
également des exigences de transparence
et de régulation financière des EHPAD il
prend également ce souhait très
largement majoritaire par Moïse nos
concitoyens devient vieillir chez soi et
pour cela il prévoit pour 680 millions
d'euros la compensation pour les
départements de la dotation qualité 3
heures 3 euros par heure s'ajoutant au
tarif plancher de 22 euros par heure
pour les services d'aide à domicile
amorçant ce vrai tournant que l'on
souhaite de nos vœux il provoque
également la bonification de la
tarification des soins infirmiers à
domicile et à compter de 2024 les
personnes âgées pourront également
bénéficier de deux heures
supplémentaires de la vie sociale de vie
sociale ce qui est à noter également
c'est que cette construction du Bien
vieillir est complétée par le PLF sur la
primadapte pour la daménagement des
logements également ce projet de loi que
nous allons examiner dans quelques jours
sur l'assurance chômage sur la
validation des acquis d'expérience pour
les proches aidants une loi grand âge
pour aborder les autres éléments autour
de la société du vieillissement serait
précieuse pour dresser un chemin
d'action mais pour cela le groupe
Renaissance soutient ce pelvss justement
merci bien Madame la Députée la parole
est à Madame Sandrine de gore sucre
rassemblement national
merci merci Madame ma présidente
monsieur le ministre ce premier PDF SS
de ce nouveau quinquennat s'inscrit
malheureusement dans la logique des
précédents et vous revendiquez même la
filiation avait le plan ma santé 2022
blanc dont vous avez vous-même démontré
l'unification en devenant lancer une
mission flash sur les urgences cet été
si la fin de la crise sanitaire fait
reculer de façon conséquente le déficit
de notre sécurité sociale les
orientations restent les mêmes
évidemment la grande question de ce
texte est une question à laquelle vous
n'avez pas la réponse vous devez comme
nous attendre la décision supérienne je
pense bien sûr à la question de la
réforme des retraites réforme aussi
inutile aucun juste
pour ce qui est de notre système de
santé je ne vois aucune mesure envergure
pour le redresser pourtant les sujets ne
manquent pas augmentation du nombre de
personnes atteintes de maladies
chroniques vieillissement de la
population
érosion des personnels soignants à
l'hôpital
raréfaction des visites à domicile
disparition des tours de garde
progression des déserts médicaux
vous refusez de sortir de cette logique
administrative
si bien incarnée pour les agences
régionales de santé
pourtant pourtant la proposition de
Marine Le Pen de mettre à la tête des
hôpitaux des binômes administratives
médecins paraît à beaucoup une
proposition de bon sens vos mesures pour
s'attaquer au désert médicaux sont
dérisoire je ne vois rien non plus pour
redonner l'espoir à tous ces personnels
soignants qui ne trouvent plus de sens à
leur métier voir qu'ils abandonnent et
enfin même si la liste est longue je ne
vois rien pour répondre à la crise des
urgences dont on voit régulièrement les
effets dans les médias
alors que nous allons débuter les
travaux sur les PLFSS permettez-moi de
vous donner trois de nos priorités
monsieur le ministre la réorganisation
de l'hôpital
la nécessaire remédicalisation des EHPAD
et le soutien aux proches aidant qui
sont aujourd'hui finalement ceux qui
font tenir tant bien que mal notre
système de soins je vous remercie
merci bien la parole est à Madame
Caroline Fiat pour la France insoumise
nupes pour 4 minutes merci madame la
Présidente messieurs les ministres même
si on peut se satisfaire de recevoir le
produit de loi de financement la
sécurité sociale plus en amont on avait
l'habitude de faire des auditions sans
donc le recevoir qu'à midi on a une
certaine habitude mais la situation est
pire qu'avant car malgré toutes les
gesticulations sur un soi-disant
changement de méthode on ne sait
toujours pas ce qu'il en est d'une
éventuelle réforme des retraites par
voie d'amendement si je résume donc vous
faites semblant d'organiser une
consultation sur un sujet que vous dites
essentiel mais qui ne figure pourtant
pas dans le texte principal et pour
lequel quasi tous les groupes de cette
assemblée vous le faisons déjà dit non
et bien pour vous faire gagner du temps
je vous le redis ici non nous ne voulons
pas de votre épouvantable réforme des
retraites et quel que soit ces modalités
vous nous trouverez sur votre chemin
pour l'empêcher monsieur le ministre
chargé des comptes publics j'ai une
question pour vous à la fois précise et
globale allez-vous enfin cesser de créer
sciemment ce que vous appelez le trou de
la Sécu dans le cas d'une réponse
négative pourriez-vous enfin admettre
que vous privilégiez les profits de
quelques-uns au détriment de la santé de
tous puisque les cotisations sont en
réalité du salaire indirect vous
continuez d'appauvrir les salariés de ce
qui leur revient en enrichissant le
capital qui loin d'augmenter les
salaires directs et gagnants sur tous
les plans pour vous tous j'ai aussi
beaucoup d'autres interrogations le
recrutement des fameux 210 000 soignants
à minima figure-t-il dans ce plfs afin
de freiner la maltraitance
institutionnelle ce sera 50 000 et
certainement pas en urgence mais sur
cinq ans où sont les autres mesures pour
les EHPAD que je vous cite et vous
recite depuis des années je sais que
vous en avez marre vous n'êtes pas prêt
d'avoir fini d'en entendre parler étant
donné que vous ne répondez pas aux
préconisations
concernant l'augmentation des prix du
tabac nos buralistes sont l'un des
derniers commerces de proximité et
l'État leur en demande toujours plus je
tiens d'ailleurs à souligner qu'il
s'appelle en réalité commerce d'utilité
locale il vivait essentiellement de la
vente de cigarettes ainsi voulez-vous la
fin de nos commerces d'utilité locale
souhaitez-vous que disparaissent en même
temps les bureaux de poste qu'ils ont
repris les billets les guichets SNCF
qu'ils ont repris pour répondre que les
Français fumeront moins ainsi le paquet
de cigarettes augmente nous avons tous
pu remarquer les chiffres erronés lors
du premier confinement où tous les
fumeurs ont repris c'était stressant
certainement ou tout du moins ont
racheté leur cigarettes en France
également avez-vous tiré des leçons de
la crise sanitaire prévoyez-vous la
création d'un pôle public du médicament
la levée des brevets sur les vaccins ou
l'ouverture de l'issue supplémentaire
dans nos hôpitaux concernant le
déremboursements de certains arrêts de
travail décidément regorger
d'ingéniosité après la chasse aux
pauvres la chasse au chômeurs la
chasseur traités maintenant la chasse
aux malades en outre je tiens à rappeler
que j'ai à plusieurs reprises et
expliquer à quel point la
téléconsultation était une mauvaise idée
et avancer les propositions de la
télémétique vous n'avez rien voulu
entendre et vous cherchez désormais
d'autres responsables à vos propres
turpitude enfin qu'attendez-vous pour
vous occuper des exclus du Ségur ces
milliers de personnes n'ont pas vraiment
l'air d'attirer votre attention puisque
aucune aucun d'entre vous pardon
messieurs les ministres ne daignent être
présent au rendez-vous que je dois
normalement avoir demain à Bercy pour
parler de la proposition de loi sur les
exclus de ce dispositif alors que ça
avait été proposé par le ministère
lui-même malheureusement je n'ai pas de
grands espoirs s'agissant de vos
réponses ce PLFSS semble donc toujours
annoncer les mêmes catastrophes
l'effondrement de l'hôpital public la
maltraitance de nos aînés la mort au
travail et ce ne sont pas les quelques
petites mesurettes que vous peignez de
prendre qui rendront enfin le droit à la
santé effective dans notre pays bien au
contraire tant que votre gouvernement
est au pouvoir être vivant et en bonne
santé semble être un luxe de plus en
plus inaccessible pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens et concitoyens
très bien Monsieur Philippe Juvin pour
le groupe les républicains merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur les ministres
bon la lecture du PLFSS du projet de FSS
montrent que la dette est devenue une
des modalités normales les pérennes
désormais de financement de la
protection sociale seul l'Espagne en est
en Europe présente une situation
similaire sur la durée cette dette est
non seulement anti-économique mais elle
fait peser un risque financier grave et
de fonctionnement sur les assurances
sociales d'ailleurs le risque en matière
de santé se réalise déjà puisque vous
connaissez tous des exemples de Français
qui malheureusement ne peuvent pas
correctement se faire soigner le risque
se réalise déjà
depuis ce déficit il est sous-estimé car
il intègre des subventions d'équilibre
implicite des pouvoirs publics sous
forme notamment de surcotisation régime
de pension des fonctionnaires civils et
militaires et sans ces surcotisations le
déficit de la Sécurité sociale serait
plus élevé d'un montant supérieur ou
égal à 30 milliards d'euros
en face déficit il est réduit
depuis par rapport à l'année dernière
mais de façon incertaine parce qu'un
certain nombre des moyens qui sont
employés pour réduire ce déficit
peuvent nous interroger 10 milliards sur
les tests et c'est légitime et vous avez
raison de prendre cette mesure mais on
voit aujourd'hui que la maladie du covid
reprend est-ce que c'est 10 milliards
c'est vraiment une une économie réelle
et un déficit
agommets certains 1,1 milliard sur les
médicaments se pose la question de
l'innovation en France on a déjà des
médicaments innovants qui ne sont pas
disponibles à nos concitoyens alors
qu'ils le sont chez nos voisins on voit
que les mesures recherchées sont en
réalité parfois contestables pour
réduire fort légitimement pourtant ce
déficit en fait ce qui nous manque c'est
une stratégie structurelle de réduction
de ces déficits et la clé est sur les
Ministres s'est amélioré la qualité ce
n'est pas le rabot et nous trouvons
qu'en fait il y a une grande
contradiction entre un coût très élevé
très élevé des dépenses de santé pour
prendre l'exemple de la santé et de
l'efficacité de ses défenses quand vous
regardez les indicateurs sanitaires bien
vous voyez que les indicateurs ne sont
pas bons et s'effondre pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux on met beaucoup
d'argent dans la santé et on en a pas
pour une autre argent alors c'est quoi
les pistes c'est faire confiance aux
acteurs et mettre en avant la qualité
est-ce que vous ne croyez pas qu'il
faudrait une stratégie par exemple je
viens de parler du covid pour la prise
en charge des covids longs qui
aujourd'hui sont un peu dans la nature
pour aller chercher tous ces cancers qui
n'ont pas été correctement diagnostiqués
et traiter est-ce que il ne faudrait pas
que l'argent aille au soins je suis
frappé de voir que
c'est un symbole certes me direz-vous
mais il n'est pas inintéressant quand
vous regardez le tableau des emplois de
la fonction publique hospitalière il y a
plus d'agents d'administration que de
médecins un rapport de l'adresse le
dernier c'est 105.000 agents
d'administration et 94.000 ETP de
médecins mais les libéraux peuvent le
dire pareil ils sont surchargés de
d'embêtement je vais le dire comme ça
poliment administratif et de
complications il faut leur faciliter la
vie
je suis d'accord avec vous il faut faire
mieux travailler la ville et l'hôpital
et le médico-social la ville et
médico-sociale il faut que les acteurs
travaillent mieux mais comment on fait
ça ne peut pas être simplement comme on
l'a dit
d'augmenter les capacités de vaccination
par eux-mêmes des infirmiers pharmaciens
il faut aller plus loin peut-être les
prescriptions infirmières enfin la
prévention vous avez raison de dire que
c'est important mais c'est une chose de
le dire il faut le faire moi je pense
que l'eau qu'on l'eau qu'on boit l'air
qu'on respire l'alimentation qu'on mange
c'est aussi de la prévention le travail
de nuit des soignants qu'il faut
revaloriser voilà monsieur le ministre
vous avez remercié à forte juste titre
les hommes et les femmes qui ont fait ce
PLFSS et je les remercie aussi je crois
quand votre nom à tous et bien moi
j'adresse merci me remerciement aux
soignants qui travaillent nuit et jour
pour tenir un système qui s'appauvrit
inexorablement
merci bien la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe Vigier pour le groupe démocrate
modem et indépendant merci madame la
Présidente
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre ce budget c'est
aussi votre pâte avec
la volonté que vous avez affichée
notamment en matière de prévention ce
sont les premiers mots que vous avez
utilisé lorsque vous avez été nommé
ministre et on en trouve les premières
les premières éléments les premières
briques avec ces fameuses trois
consultations et avec notamment en
matière de santé sexuelle et de
reproduction et des avancées notoires et
tenez également monture à le souligner
au nom du groupe et simplement que vous
disiez que cette première étape sur la
prévention en appellera d'autres et pour
nous éclairer sur cette politique long
terme que vous souhaitez conduire
notamment vous savez qu'il y a un
éclatement de ces politiques de
prévention à l'heure actuelle est-ce que
oui ou non au nom de l'efficacité vous
allez les rejoindre les rassembler dans
une seule direction générale la seconde
chose est d'ailleurs Gabriel Attal a eu
des mots très fort sur les luttes contre
social et fiscal ça me rappelle un
rapport parlementaire que les filles il
y a quelques années je crois que la suis
oui faut pas avoir la main qui tremble
parce que tous ces soins
qui sont pas justifiés ou s'il y a de la
part d'assistante du professionnel des
débordements inacceptables je crois
qu'il faut vraiment y mettre fin parce
que c'est une capacité d'investissement
que nous perdons pour d'autres patients
et dans la lutte contre la fraudation
maladie vous nous trouvera à vos côtés
parce que nous ne pouvons pas continuer
ainsi deuxième question monsieur le
ministre concernant l'accès aux soins et
des Herbiers médicaux vous en parlez
Stéphanie risque indique quelques mots
tout à l'heure
au-delà de ce qui va être possible pour
la vaccination l'élargissant sur les
régularisations des padues sur les
délégations de tâches est-ce que vous
irez jusqu'à des modifications de
conventionnement parce qu'on voit bien
que le cœur du problème c'est le nombre
d'heures du médecin disponibles
d'autres collègues ont cité également
les premiers certificats de décès la
santé au travail qui est un véritable
sujet par exemple avec peut-être la
possibilité pour des infirmières au
travail plus former encore des
participer à ce chaînage indispensable
puisque c'est des arts médicaux vous le
savez font l'objet de ce de groupe à
l'heure actuelle qui réfléchissent sur
des propositions et assurez-vous ouverts
dans le cadre du pvss pour prendre un
certain nombre de propositions qui vous
seront faites et troisième sujet c'est
pour votre voisin Jean-Christophe conte
donc on a créé cette cinquième branche
qui a suscité naturellement beaucoup
d'attente alors j'espère que
2023 va être une année riche et bien
compris que vous allez mettre 560
millions d'euros sur la branche mais
j'imagine que 2023 va être un moment
charnière très important pour bâtir
cette grande loi que nous attendons
dépendance parce que cette grande loi
grand âge elle est attendue par tous
enfin sur la drone on affiche un andain
à 3,7%, 4,1 à l'hôpital
aurez-vous les moyens de faire face aux
investissements prévus aux dérives du
hall d'inflation au surcoût du à
l'énergie et revalorisation des salaires
sur les médicaments ça a été un peu
effleuré tout à l'heure c'est depuis 15
ans dans l'habitude de raboter
malheureusement les dépenses médicaments
et est-ce que oui ou non on va pouvoir
inverser cette tendance folle que nous
connaissons c'est que chaque année il y
a toujours plus de spécialités qui
manquent à l'hôpital ou en ville et je
crois que un véritable in sourcing la
production des médicaments en France et
en Europe pourraient être une ambition
importante
peut-être monsieur le ministre soit
Brown dans les prochaines années la
gouvernance de l'hôpital sera j'imagine
sur votre bureau pour la modifier quand
on connaît les limites à l'heure
actuelle vous connaissez parfaitement
d'hospitalier est-ce que accroître le
rôle des médecins et plus écouté
naturellement les usagers n'est pas une
voie empruntée pour pas laisser la
technostructure hospitalière avoir la
main sur la vie de tous nos
établissements enfin un dernier mot
concernant
les nouvelles directions que vous avez
lancées concernant le numérique et les
espaces santé numérique est-ce que cette
nouvelle direction qui commence vraiment
à bien irriguer les territoires et qui
est un gage d'efficacité sera accéléré
dans son déploiement permettant j'en
suis persuadé une meilleure efficience
donc de porter une meilleure réponse à
nos concitoyens merci merci bien
monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Jérôme Guedj pour le groupe
socialiste et apprend à parenté nupes
oui merci madame la Présidente j'ai
cherché un terme en plongeant depuis ce
midi dans le plfs pour le qualifier
celui-ci et le contexte dans lequel nous
abordé comme je suis un garçon
sympathique et bienveillant je me suis
arrêté sur le terme de baroque mais
j'aurais pu être plus sévère pourquoi
c'est baroque parce que pour plusieurs
choses vous avez annoncé d'abord et ça a
encore été dit par Gabriel Attal que
tout ceci se faisait dans un esprit de
compromis on entend cette petite
ancienne depuis
le début de la session parlementaire je
constate néanmoins que contrairement à
nos collègues de la commission des
finances la commission de l'affaire
sociale n'a pas eu le droit au dialogue
de Bercy et de Ségur pour débattre du
contenu de ce plfs c'est quand même 570
milliards contre les 480 milliards de
l'État donc le jour où on sera à parité
on pourra considérer qu'on est aussi
bien traité mais plus sérieusement ou en
complément vous nous dites vous allez
enrichir ce texte mais vous savez aussi
bien que nous que la recevabilité des
amendements que nous proposerons
empêchera probablement le travail
d'enrichissement qu'on pourrait et
surtout ça a été dit par Caroline Fiat
vous avez d'emblée fait peser sur ce
texte une formidable une gigantesque une
improbable épée de Damoclès en mettant
sur la table éventualité d'un amendement
pour débattre d'une réforme et j'aimais
beaucoup de guillemets des retraites et
le cas échéant de la faire voter par
49-3 j'y reviendrai mais alors alors que
toutes plaider en réalité pour qu'on ait
un PLFSS vous allez voir je suis
sympathique et bienveillant qui soit
plus roboratif j'en ai connu bénéfice de
l'âge des PLFSS depuis différents
endroits et très sincèrement je vous le
dis avec beaucoup d'estime pour beaucoup
d'entre vous on reste considérablement
sur notre fin on est dans un plfs de
début de mandature après des engagements
ça ressemble à un père FSS un peu de
fond de fin de mandature on sort d'une
crise sanitaire on a un pouvoir d'achat
en berne et notamment des difficultés
pour les familles monoparentales les
urgences l'hôpital public l'accès aux
soins malmenés la crise ORPEA les
promesses de réforme depuis 4 ans sur la
question du grand âge et de tout ça et
ben on ne trouve rien en réalité alors
vous vous payez de mots vous nous dites
il y a d'ailleurs quelqu'un chez vous
dans les éléments de langage qui doit
s'éclater parce que vous nous parlez de
briques pour répondre aux défis de
demain tout à l'heure François Brune
parler de la première pierre du mur
porteur etc mais pardon mettre des
briques des murs porteurs si on n'a pas
de plan d'ensemble ça fait pas tenir une
maison parce que les briques vous les
mettez comme ça de manière disparate et
en fait on ne sait pas où vous allez en
réalité je prends deux illustrations
vous nous renvoyez s'agissant de la
santé au Conseil national de la
refondation ex conseil des parties
prenantes qui va se réunir bon mais on
ne voit pas la cohérence d'ensemble est
sur un sujet qui me tient à cœur pardon
de le dire notamment à Jean-Christophe
combe mais je suis très triste qu'il ait
été celui qui est dû porter
l'enterrement de première classe de la
loi grand âge et l'autonomie dont vous
avez compris que dans ces banques tout
le monde l'appel de ses vœux et vous
nous avez dit à l'époque vous avez dit
il y a pas besoin d'une loi grand âge et
autonomie on pourra faire des choses
dans le PLFSS sincèrement quand on
regarde s'il y a dans le PLFSS c'est un
peu
offensant la première ministre dit 50000
postes d'epad a créé dans les 5 années
dans son discours de politique générale
tout le monde s'accorde à dire que c'est
pas assez la FAF dit il faudrait trois
fois ou quatre fois plus mais là on est
sur la première année de cette mesure et
vous créez 3000 postes c'est à dire un
tiers de l'objectif alors vous allez me
dire difficulté de recrutement mais vous
envoyez un signal délétère à tous ceux
qui pensent c'est pas avec un demi poste
de plus dans les 7200 ehpad de France
que vous avez allé vous allez améliorer
les conditions de travail vous créez
deux heures de lien social dans les dans
les plans d'aide on sait pas ce que
c'est personne ne sait exactement y
compris ce que sera cette mesure et j'ai
une question d'ailleurs sur le bouclier
tarifaire j'ai cherché mais j'ai pas
bien compris les mesures qui
permettaient de protéger de l'inflation
les établissements deux remarques pour
terminer on parle chiffres le plus
important quand même c'est la première
fois qu'on a un PLFSS avec un nom d'âme
qui est inférieur à l'inflation c'est la
première fois depuis 1996 alors je
voudrais que vous mesuriez le décalage
et les conséquences que cela peut avoir
dans les trois sets que vous préconisez
il y a quand même 0,4 points qui sont
liés au point d'indice et donc vous
pourrez pas vous réfugier derrière un
nom d'âme en apparence important mais
qui en réalité nous met en oeuvre aucune
des mesures essentielles merci Thomas
Meunier pour le groupe horizon et à
parenté merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres madame la
Présidente de la Commission madame la
rapportée en général chers collègues le
PLFSS et chaque année un moment
important de notre vie parlementaire un
moment de débat et de choix essentiels
pour notre protection sociale véritable
trésor national je me réjouis que nous
entamions cette discussion plutôt cette
année grâce aux nouveaux cadres
organiques que j'ai porté et qui nous
permettra d'avoir le temps de travailler
plus en avant le PLFSS je salue comme
vous monsieur le ministre toutes celles
et ceux qui ont contribué à sa
préparation
une autre raison d'être positif alors
d'entamer nos discussions tient à la
réduction du déficit annoncé par ce
PLFSS après des déficits historiques
39,7 milliards d'euros en 2020 le solde
des régimes obligatoires de base et du
Fonds de solidarité vieillesse c'est
redresser en 2021 et 2022 sous l'effet
de la politique menée de la reprise
économique et des créations d'emplois le
déficit devrait atteindre 17,8 milliards
d'euros en 2022 vous l'estimez à 6,8
milliards en 2023 c'est encourageant
avant des perspectives d'aggravation à
horizon 2026 notamment dans la branche
vieillesse à hauteur de 15,9 milliards
d'euros cela implique d'engager une
réforme des retraites et je veux le dire
ici quel que soit le moment où les
modalités proposées par le gouvernement
vous aurez le groupe horizon à vos côtés
pour mener à bien cette réforme
messieurs les ministres j'en reviens au
texte présenté aujourd'hui l'ONDAM hors
crise de 3,7% avec un nom d'âme
établissement de santé à 4,1 ce qui doit
permettre une nouvelle fois après la LSS
2022 de ne procéder à aucune économie
sur l'hôpital c'est essentiel je salue
nos soignants nos soignants qui
dénoncent les dérives de l'intérim
véritable cancer de l'hôpital public il
fait l'objet d'une mesure dans ce PLFSS
pouvez-vous nous en détailler la portée
monsieur le ministre ne craignez-vous
pas qu'elle soit contournée par des
contrats de gré à grille dès le début de
carrière quand comptez-vous prendre le
décret de la loi riste que nous avons
voté en 2021 une autre mesure semble
interrogée parmi les acteurs la
quatrième année de médecine générale
promesse de campagne du président de la
République un internat harmonisé le
statut de docteur Junior sont des
perspectives intéressantes mais
soulèvent quelques questions quand la
mission annoncée rendra-t-elle ses
conclusions dans quelle temporalité sera
mise en oeuvre la réforme avez-vous
d'ores et déjà évaluer l'impact de
retarder d'un an l'arrivée de toute une
promotion sur le terrain
le ministère de la Santé est également
celui de la prévention à ce titre le
PLFSS va de l'avant avec les
consultations aux âges clés de la vie
avec l'accès élargi à la vaccination
chez les professionnels de santé avec la
lutte contre le tabagisme le groupe
horizon il souscrit totalement nous
saluons également les diverses mesures
visant à lutter contre la fraude je peux
notamment citer celle concernant les
arrêts de travail qui ont explosé ces
derniers mois par le biais de la
téléconsultation comme vous le rappeliez
hier monsieur le ministre j'aurais
souhaité aborder la question du
médicament la question également du
cannabis thérapeutique pour savoir
quelle perspective vous comptez donner à
l'expérimentation qui touche à sa fin
monsieur le ministre mais je dois
avancer pris par le temps et souhaite
avancer sur tous les sujets de ce PLFSS
je ne reviens pas sur la branche famille
rapporter par Paul Christophe sauf à
saluer l'extension des 6 de 6 à 12 ans
de l'enfant du complément de libre choix
du mode de garde pour les familles
monoparentales
et je reviens enfin sur la cinquième
branche autonomie qui deux ans après sa
création et après une année 2022 marquée
par un travail en faveur de
l'attractivité des métiers
l'instauration d'un tarif plancher et
d'une dotation qualité prend un peu plus
score avec une forte progression du
financement du soutien de l'autonomie en
2023 avec un objectif global de dépenses
en hausse de 5,2% pour les personnes
âgées de 5,1% pour les personnes en
situation de handicap
renforcer la présence des soignants
auprès des résidents on EHPAD lutter
contre l'isolement au domicile
sont autant de promesses de campagne qui
se concrétisent dans ce plfs sur ces
mesures et sur l'ensemble du texte le
groupe horizon vous assure de son
soutien et de sa volonté de protéger
toujours plus les Français et de
garantir la soutenabilité de notre
modèle social très bien monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame Sandrine
Rousseau pour écologie nupes
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres alors vous nous aviez dit que
vous changeriez de méthode que cette
mandature serait celle du dialogue de la
concertation sociale vous nous l'aviez
promis même la main sur le cœur l'objet
même de votre conseil national de
refondation et de ses groupes de travail
en même temps Olivier Véran puis
aujourd'hui Elisabeth borne nous
explique que le passage de la réforme
des retraites sous la forme d'un simple
amendement du PLFSS pourrait être
envisagée je vous propose de passer cet
amendement vers 3h du matin pour montrer
aux Français et Françaises votre
capacité à concerter et votre volonté
vraiment de la du compromis
alors sur le pdfss de d'ailleurs vous
n'en avez rien dit ici il y a pas eu un
mot sur la question des retraites alors
même que c'est l'épée de Damoclès comme
le disait très justement mon collègue
tout à l'heure qui plane sur ce PLFSS
alors sur le PLFSS en lui-même un
constat simple l'hôpital était en crise
et bien après les fesses il sera
toujours en crise dans ce projet de loi
sur la sécurité sociale et bien
l'inflation est insuffisamment compensée
le financement de l'ONDAM n'est pas
aligné sur l'inflation il ne permettra
pas le financement des établissements
cela va inévitablement mener à une
aggravation des restrictions budgétaires
vous nous disiez monsieur le ministre
qu'il y avait une stagnation vous vous
en réjouissez l'hôpital se meurt et vous
regardez ailleurs par ailleurs la France
ne dépensera en 2023 qu'un milliard
d'euros pour lutter contre le covid
contre 12 milliards en 2022 une
provision qui a d'ores et déjà qualifiée
de 13 insuffisante par le Haut Conseil
des finances publiques consultez pour
avis dans le cadre de l'élaboration de
ce PLFSS et surtout les économies vous
en faites beaucoup comment justifier
vous en contexte de crise sanitaire
alors que seul 5,1 millions des Français
et Françaises ont un médecin traitant
déclaré et alors que l'Observatoire de
la Mutualité française estime à 7,4
millions le nombre de nos concitoyens et
concitoyens qui vivent dans les déserts
médicaux de proposer de rembourser les
arrêts de travail délivrés en
téléconsultation par un médecin autre
que son médecin traitant votre priorité
est-elle réellement de garantir à tous
et toutes sur tout le territoire un
accès aux soins permettait que nous en
doutions vous auriez pu pour assurer la
pour assurer le financement de le
financement des recettes regardez du
côté des cotisations patronales qui est
inlassablement ont diminué depuis
1990 et aujourd'hui ce sont les ménages
qui sont les premiers financeurs de la
sécurité sociale devant les entreprises
qui est historiques je me permets de
douter aussi des de votre volonté
d'accès aux soins de l'ensemble des
Français et Françaises car sur
l'autonomie votre projet est insuffisant
aussi bien du point de vue des mesures
destinées aux personnes âgées que des
mesures à destination des personnes en
situation de handicap aucune proposition
ni est faite pour transformer en
profondeur ce secteur en difficulté
pourtant les rapports lipo et elshomri
commandés par vos prédécesseurs ce
succèdent et faisait déjà étendre d'une
situation extrêmement préoccupante face
aux enjeux d'une population qui vit plus
longtemps et se voit avec le temps
davantage exposé au risque sociaux et
environnementaux une action d'ampleur
est nécessaire la perte d'attractivité
des métiers de l'autonomie est alarmante
la baisse de 25 % en 6 ans des
candidatures au concours d'accès aux
métiers clés d'aide-soignant et
d'accompagnant éducatifs et social en
est un exemple cette perte
d'attractivité vient par ailleurs se
heurter à la volonté croissante des
Français et Françaises de vieillir à
domicile souhait renforcer par les
scandales à répétition dans les EHPAD
vous auriez pu transformer en profondeur
encore une fois le Motel des EHPAD qui
nécessitent une réforme urgente et poser
ce constat simple on ne fait pas de
profit sur la vie de nos anciens face au
manque de moyens humains et financiers
au manque d'accompagnement psychologique
des personnels et au manque de
reconnaissance de ces métiers cruciaux
que promettez-vous une politique de
mesurette et aucun plan d'investissement
d'ampleur dans la 5ème branche pour
rappel le rapport Libeau estimé besoin
du secteur de l'autonomie à 6 milliards
en 2024 et 10 milliards en 2030 par
ailleurs
très bien monsieur monsieur monsieur le
député d'arriville à la parole et lui
seul s'il vous plaît
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres de la de tout votre marketing
autour de la refondation on écoute cela
tout ce que vous nous avez présenté vous
avez la responsabilité vous t’en
discuter pour de vrai avec le Parlement
et nous allons commencer tant bien que
mal puisque le écoutez je vous arrête
quelques minutes s'il vous plaît qu'on
puisse écouter le député très bien no
comment Monsieur le Député vous avez la
parole et vous seul
nous allons commencer tant bien que mal
puisque nous n'avons eu votre texte que
voici quelques heures il y a certains
d'ensemble de mesures que vous mettez en
avant et qui vont dans le bon sens la
revalorisation de la location de soutien
familiale la gratuité de la
contraception d'urgence mais en réalité
c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt la
forêt qui brûle et vous ne répondez pas
aux urgences sociales de notre pays à
son nombreuses elles ont été amplifiées
par cette crise c'est urgences se sont
d'abord celles des ruptures de parcours
de soins parce que au choix politique
ont asphyxié les hôpitaux publics qui
sont en crise et c'est personnels qui
sont en révolte contre cette situation
les fermetures de lit de service le
virage ambulatoire qui a surtout profité
au secteur privé ont largement participé
à amplifier la désertification médicale
le dernier rapport de l'adresse vient
d'ailleurs de confirmer le creusement
des inégalités territoriales mais
également socio-économique face à la
santé à partir de 35 ans les hommes
cadres vivent en moyenne 6 ans de plus
que les ouvriers et cette écart de trois
ans chez les femmes cet écart se creuse
selon que l'on vit dans le nord dans
l'Est ou dans les outre-mer être pauvre
multiplie par 3,2 le risque de
renoncement aux soins le contexte de
pénurie de l'offre n'arrange rien aussi
ayant en tête que près de 6 millions de
Français n'ont pas et de Français n'ont
pas de médecin traitant déclaré ainsi si
votre texte prend acte que nous devons
combler notre retard en terme de
prévention la mise en place de
rendez-vous de la prévention qui pour
partie existe déjà ne résoudra pas le
problème de ceux qui se sont éloignés de
la prévention et des soins nous
institutions existantes sont d'ailleurs
profondément affaiblies PMI médecine du
travail santé scolaire la santé mentale
est également un grand absent de ce
texte et pourtant les rapports à la
matière sont accablants une personne sur
5 est touché chaque année par un trouble
psychique en 40 ans deux tiers des lits
ont été fermés le nombre de patients est
passé de 1 million en 97 à 2,3 millions
en 2020 la désertification médicale qui
n'est plus l'apanage des petites villes
ou des milieux ruraux la principale
mesure que vous proposez face à cela
d'or c'est déjà très controversé par les
principaux intéressés peut-être par
manque de concertation entre autres et
d'allonger d'un an la durée d'internat
pour les médecins généralistes pour les
encourager dites-vous à exercer en zone
sous dense il s'agit peut-on lire dans
le dossier de presse de capitaliser sur
les mesures d'urgence prise cet été mais
avant de capitaliser serait-il possible
vous l'avez évoqué d'avoir un bilan
détaillé de ces mesures nous créons
d'ailleurs qu'elle soit pérennisées où
en sont les mesures tant attendues pour
l'hôpital public les hôpitaux
attendaient une rallonge de 2 milliards
d'euros pour cette année afin de
compenser l'inflation et espérer quatre
à cinq milliards de plus pour 2023 ce
PLFSS ensemble bien loin l'ensemble des
personnels soignants et administratifs
ont besoin d'une véritable
revalorisation salariale mais également
de moyens humains et matériels
supplémentaires et comme toujours c'est
là que le bât blesse ce PLFSS c'est une
fois de plus un budget qui limite les
dépenses sans se donner les moyens de
recettes nouvelles et on y sacrifiant au
passage les besoins de la population
vous prévoyez en effet une hausse des
recettes de 4,1% assis sur la hausse des
prix et des salaires mais surtout vous
plafonner les dépenses à de progression
et vous procédez à certaines économies
avec une volonté symbolique qui ne vous
aura pas échappé avec l'insistance que
vous y avez mise comme à l'article 43
qui prévoit de conditionner
drastiquement le remboursement des
arrêts de travail délivrés par
téléconsultation alors que vous incitez
par ailleurs fortement à la télé mais de
Sin après des années de compensation
votre Honda est toujours pas au niveau
de l'augmentation mécanique des dépenses
et encore moins au niveau des besoins
vous sous-estimez les dépenses à venir
celles de prévention et de lutte contre
le covid puisque réduite de 11 à 1
milliard mais vous ne semblez pas tenir
compte également du rattrapage de soins
mise en suspens lors de la pandémie
selon la CNAM la pandémie a entraîné en
2020 un million de déprogrammations
chirurgicales soient plus de 18% du
volume annuel nous avons un besoin
criant d'un grand service public de
l'autonomie nous avons besoin de lutter
contre la marchandisation de la santé je
terminerai en parlant
si vous me le permettez j'ai pris en
compte
très bien merci
merci donc en matière de financement
vous voulez augmenter la part du travail
et tout en évitant soigneusement les
augmentations de salaire vous continuez
à exonérer le capital la protection
sociale a besoin de financement ils
existent enfin si vous voulez agir pour
la santé la prévention la dame la
présidence faite une chose simple
renoncée à casser le droit à la retraite
et à nous faire travailler plus
longtemps vous ne nous avez pas saisi
aujourd'hui les déserts trop tard
prenons saisi dans le
pays tout court
André Colombani pour liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoire chers collègues
je vous prierai de respecter le temps
qui vous est imparti voilà
présidente monsieur le ministre Mesdames
et Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues cette année le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
nous est présenté avec un peu d'avance
sur le calendrier habituel mais la
méthode de co-construction des textes
législatifs que nous avait promis le
gouvernement ne semble pas s'appliquer à
ce texte aussi nous n'avons que peu de
recul sur les mesures qu'il contient je
m'attacherai donc à présenter les
chantiers que mon groupe estime
prioritaire d'abord il y a la question
de l'accès aux soins la situation de
l'hôpital public continue à être
préoccupante au-delà de l'encadrement de
l'intérim nous ne voyons pas de mesure
pour donner plus de moyens humains et
financiers aux établissements la crise
de l'hôpital public est indissociable le
désertification médicale pour l'endiguer
vous proposez l'instauration d'une
quatrième année du 3 au 3e cycle de
médecine générale
là-dessus je m'interroge sur les comptes
parties prévues pour éviter de
découragement de étudiants qui
pourraient être incités à se tourner
vers d'autres spécialités
nous nous interrogeons aussi sur la
cohérence du gouvernement souhaitant
d'une part développer les
téléconsultations et d'autre part
restreindre les ninisation des arrêts de
travail prescrit en téléconsultation
uniquement à ceux délivrer par le
médecin traitant et quand sera-t-il pour
ceux n'ayant pas de médecin traitant et
on sait combien ils sont nombreux
en revanche nous ne voyons d'un bon œil
le renforcement du volet prévention avec
l'organisation de consultation dédiées
mais aussi l'accès facilité graduée à la
contraception d'urgence et au dépistage
des IST
la deuxième priorité de notre groupe
concerne le soutien l'autonomie la loi
grande tâche et autonomie promise pour
lors du principe du précédent de
quinquennat a-t-elle été abandonnée et
en plus de deux ans après sa création la
branche autonomie n'a toujours pas de
financement à d'autres n'oublions pas
les difficultés de recrutement des
personnels en établissement et à
domicile sont qui sont toujours
d'actualité les mesures à l'issue du
Ségur n'ont pas été une ont été qu'une
première étape que prévoyez-vous pour y
remédier nous notons un point positif le
renforcement des mesures de contrôle des
EHPAD pour que le scandale d'orpa ne se
reproduise plus jamais mais pourquoi ne
pas aller au-delà en revoyant par
exemple le mode de financement des
établissements y compris pour y réduire
le reste à charge des résidents
une inquiétude demeure par rapport à la
capacité des établissements assurer
correctement leur mission dans le
contexte d'augmentation des coûts
énergétiques un regret toutefois que la
question de l'autonomie soit traitée
prescription sous l'oeil du
vieillissement et moins sous celui du
handicap quasiment absent du texte
un dernier champ un dernier chantier
prioritaire est celui de la
soutenabilité de notre système de
protection sociale notre groupe déplore
que le sujet des retraites ne soit
abordé dans le débat public qu'au
travers d'un seul angle de la situation
financière nous nous opposons à tout
amendement gouvernemental visant
augmenter la durée du travail si une
telle réforme devait avoir lieu elle
devrait aborder la pénibilité des
inégalités homme-femme l'emploi des
seniors le montant des pensions le PLFSS
n'est pas le bon véhicule législatif
et contrairement à ce qui a évoqué le
président de la République ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas au système de retraite de
financer d'autres réformes aussi
indispensables soient-elles au contraire
la question de la soutenabilité de notre
système de protection sociale doit
inciter à réfléchir à une contribution
de des plus hauts revenus et des super
profits je vous remercie
merci
je voudrais simplement avant de leur
donner la parole leur dire que nous
avons vous dire également que nous avons
encore 16 questions donc messieurs les
ministres vous avez la parole on va
commencer par Monsieur François Braun
il y a quelqu'un qui a laissé son micro
je voilà allez-y monsieur le ministre
oui merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés merci pour
toutes ces questions qui témoignent de
votre volonté de faire avancer un petit
peu les différents sujets et comme je
l'ai dit je suis pour la discussion pour
le travail collectif et sortir un peu
des postures des uns et des autres pour
avancer pour le bien de nos concitoyens
pour le bien de l'hôpital que je connais
encore un peu et pour les problématiques
liées à la psychiatrie aux urgences mais
je vais revenir sur un sur un certain
nombre de points alors je vais revenir
je suis désolé pierre par pierre parce
que je pense que c'est effectivement en
réglant les problèmes l'un après l'autre
que l'on arrivera à sortir de cette
situation particulièrement difficile
madame la rapporteur général vous avez
posé un certain nombre de questions je
vais revenir sur
un des éléments essentiels qui est vous
l'avez dit de libérer du temps médical
libéré du temps médical cette essentiel
parce que répondre aux enjeux que nous
avons aujourd'hui nous allons le faire
avec les troupes dont nous disposons
aujourd'hui
certes nous allons augmenter les
médecins certes nous allons augmenter
les infirmières mais ils seront pas
présent demain sur les territoires donc
c'est bien avec les troupes présentes
que nous allons pouvoir avancer pour
cela libérer du temps médical et plus
largement du temps de soin est essentiel
pour libérer du temps de soin ça a été
demandé je vais répondre un peu à toutes
les questions en même temps je suis
désolé nous allons là aussi lutter
contre les bureaucratismes toutes ces
tâches administratives
inutiles
utilisez des assistants médicaux puisque
nous savons que ils permettent
d'augmenter de 10% la clientèle d'un
médecin sont les résultats de la caisse
d'assurance maladie mais aussi à
l'échelle de l'hôpital retrouver le
fonctionnement à l'échelle des services
et rapprocher les administrations et les
travailleurs administratifs qui
travaillent j'en suis le témoin qui
travaille le plus près des services pour
libérer tous les soignants de ce temps
de soin et les médecins étant médical
autre possibilité pour libérer du temps
médical c'est effectivement le partage
d'activités entre les professionnels de
santé vous parliez de l'accès direct aux
IPA effectivement les votes
d'expérimentation qui ont été faites
dans la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale de l'année dernière
nous n'avons pas encore lancé ces
expérimentations les travaux avancés je
m'engage à ce que ces expérimentations
puissent être lancées en décembre pour
ce qui est de l'accès direct aux IPA et
en janvier pour ce qui est de l'accès
direct ou masseur kinésithérapeute
parler également de la santé de nos
jeunes professionnels de santé alors des
internes mais plus largement la santé
des soignants d'une façon générale
préoccupe beaucoup plus largement que
simplement celle des internes et nous
avons là aussi à conduire des actions
sur la protection de la santé des
soignants en jouant essentiellement sur
la pénibilité pénibilité qui est bien
sûr la pénibilité liée au travail au
sein de l'hôpital et je prends ça en
particulier avec la pénibilité du
travail de nuit d'ailleurs il vous a pas
échappé que dans les mesures flash de
cet été nous avons doublé même si c'est
peut-être pas beaucoup mais nous avons
doublé l'indemnité de nuit pour les
infirmières nous allons voir très
prochainement les résultats de la
mission flash voir si comme je l'ai dit
elles sont efficaces nous les
prolongerons
monsieur Bazin vous m'avez parlé de la
réforme de la médecine du travail donc
c'est très forme qui quelque part est
issue d'un accord interprofessionnel de
décembre 2020 assez inédite d'ailleurs
et qui a aboutit à une proposition de
loi portée par la députée Charlotte le
copain Parmentier que je tiens à saluer
ici
proposition de loi votée à l'unanimité
d'ailleurs en mars 2021 les décrets
d'application sont en cours se mettent
en place progressivement avec
particulier la transformation des
services de santé au travail en service
de prévention et de santé au travail
donc forcément ce terme de prévention
correspond tout à fait aux objectifs de
prévention que j'ai pu présenter tout à
l'heure et en particulier une visite à
mi-carrière pour tous les salariés de 45
ans vous échappera pas bien sûr que les
visites de prévention même si elles ont
un intérêt à se cumuler mais en tout cas
permettront de prendre en charge mieux
nos concitoyens à ces différents âges de
la vie la médecine du travail comme
d'autres comme la PMI et d'autres quand
même des ressources médicales bien sûr
nous travaillons avec Olivier dussobe
également là-dessus qui est concerné
plus directement mais là aussi l'intérêt
de mettre en place des infirmières en
pratique avancées que ce soit une
infirmière de premier recours des
infirmières gériatrie également pour les
EHPAD des infirmières de santé publique
de l'enfant bref les réflexions que nous
avons à convenir tous ensemble et sur
les bases du CNR santé sur l'extension
du champ des hyper
alors madame Thévenot
vous demandiez quels étaient le contenu
des visites de ces visites de prévention
et de campagne de communication qui
allait aller avec alors tout d'abord
bien entendu une vigilance particulière
à tous les âges se rapporter pour la
santé des femmes la visite de 25 ans 20
25 ans c'est d'ailleurs au même moment
que la visite de prévention de santé
sexuelle donc il faut le il faut le
relever continuer ses visites et bien
sûr le début de la carrière 20-25 ans on
sera orienté justement sur tout ce qui
est prévention sexuelle la vérification
des vaccins savoir si les gens à mettre
ça traitant la recherche des addictions
bien sûr l'activité physique et sportive
sur l'ensemble des visites pour 45 ans
même si ça reste global on centrera plus
sur la prévention des cancers cancers du
col bien entendu et on pourra parler
aussi dans la prévention de la
vaccination contre le papillomavirus
cancer du sein cancer colorectaux cancer
de la prostate et puis la visite un peu
plus avancée avant la visite de 75 ans
qui est déjà prévu 110 115 ans une
visite de 65 ans à peu près qui sera
pour le dépistage de la perte
d'autonomie particulièrement important à
faire à ce moment-là bien sûr le plan
endométriose continue dans sa dans sa
déclinaison
[Musique]
de la problématique de la prévention qui
est plus globale je vous rejoins en ce
sens la prévention elle est maintenant
dans un concept de santé globale dit one
Elf pour meilleure signe le comité le
nouveau comité de veille et d'alerte
sanitaire qui est mis en place et que
nous aurons avec Sylvie Retailleau
l'honneur de mettre en place
complètement dans les jours qui viennent
à une logique vous pourrez le constater
ou à Elf puisqu'il intègre en son sein
aussi bien des vétérinaires que
climatologues et que psychologue pour
vraiment prendre en charge l'ensemble
des problématiques de santé l'ensemble
de des mesures et je réponds à plusieurs
questions qui ont été posées là-dessus
qui sont dans ce dans ce PLFSS on nature
à s'enrichir bien sûr des discussions
avec le Parlement mais des discussions
au sein du Conseil national de la
refondation dans sa version santé donc
je lancerai lundi prochain
avec quatre axes principaux qui seront
un médecin traitant pour les plus
fragiles la permanence des soins bien
entendu la tractivité des métiers de la
santé par territoire et comment intégrer
la prévention dans ces parcours
les discussions s'enrichiront également
des mesures de l'été puisque j'ai
demandé deux rapports à Liga sur les
mesures d'été qui rapportent qu'ils
doivent être fournis à la fin du mois
puisqu'on avait dit qu'on allait jusqu'à
fin septembre un rapport spécifique sur
la régulation médicale et un rapport
plus global sur les autres 40 mesures de
l'été
[Musique]
alors il était posé également des
questions par Madame degor Suk sur la
gouvernance de l'hôpital la gouvernance
de l'hôpital la gouvernance du système
de santé d'ailleurs dans son ensemble
tout en tout en reconnaissant le travail
quotidien remarquable fait par les ARS
et également le travail fait par les
directions d'hôpitaux indispensable au
fonctionnement de notre service public
hospitalier un travail sur la
gouvernance de l'hôpital sera lancée lui
aussi avant la fin d'année sur le mode
CNR c'est-à-dire avec systématiquement
dans les discussions nos concitoyens des
professionnels de santé et les élus
la crise des urgences oui je l'ai déjà
dit plusieurs fois la crise des urgences
n'est pas une crise des urgences bien
une crise du système de santé et comme
je l'ai dit les missions flash puisque
maintenant c'est le terme va apporter
des conclusions par rapport IGAS avant
la fin du mois comme je l'ai dit dès le
départ si les mesures sont efficaces si
elles ont répondu des difficultés
d'accès aux soins et bien elles seront
pérennisées
madame Fiat vous m'avez interpellé sur
deux points essentiellement sur lesquels
je vais répondre sur la problématique du
tabac le tabac c'est d'abord un enjeu de
prévention et de santé publique les
pathologies associées au tabac sont
responsables de près de 74 000 décès par
an en France c'est pour ça nous avons
conduit lors du président quinquennat
une trajectoire fiscale ambitieuse
portant le prix du paquet de cigarettes
à 10 euros la fiscalité du tabac va pas
dans les poches de l'état bien entendu
ils sont les droits d'assis entièrement
affectés à l'assurance maladie et
la part qui revient vers l'assurance
maladie et deux fois inférieur ou le
coup direct du tabac pour notre système
de santé on peut parler d'environ 14
milliards d'euros de rendement contre 20
à 26 milliards d'euros de coûts
la politique a quand même porté ses
fruits puisque entre 2017 et 2021 la
prévalence du tabagisme a baissé de 3
points c'est santé publique France qui
nous le dit
signifiant que 2 millions de Français
ont arrêté de fumer au cours de ces cinq
dernières années le MS a encore
récemment décrit la France comme un des
pays et un déployé la politique fiscale
efficace pour prévenir la prévalence du
tabagisme c'est les jeunes réduire la
consommation chez les adultes et
accompagner celles et ceux qui
souhaitent arrêter de fumer je rappelle
que les substituts du tabac pour ceux
qui souhaitent arrêter de fumer sont
pris en charge
spfss vit simplement à ne pas défaire en
2023 car si nous ne faisons rien le prix
du tabac qui n'est pas entièrement
indexé à l'inflation mais plafonné à
plus 1,8% serait d'évaluer par un
zooport aux autres biens de consommation
dans le contexte actuel d'une inflation
sup à 5% par cohérence nous proposons
donc de déplafonner la part tarifaire
droit d'assise et de l'indexer sur
l'inflation de l'année n-1 comme
beaucoup d'autres impôts le prix du
paquet serait donc augmenté de 50
centimes en 2023 de la même façon nous
proposons de d'uniformiser les
retenues et d'incinant sur l'ensemble
des produits du tabac puisque on voit se
déplacer d'autres formes de consommation
que ce soit vers le tabac rouler mais
surtout vers d'autres formes de tabac à
fumer plus 130% entre 2018 et 2020 et en
particulier le tabac à chauffer
sur les arrêts de travail dans le cadre
de la téléconsultation plusieurs
questions ont porté là-dessus je pense
déjà qu'il faut être précis sur les sur
les chiffres ces arrêts de travail on
représenté 110000 arrêts de travail
l'année dernière ils en représenté la
moitié moins l'année précédente et ils
vont représenter deux fois plus cette
année sur ces 110 000 à travail déjà la
première chose qu'il faut savoir c'est
que le profil des patients exactement le
même pour ces arrêts de travail que pour
les arrêts de travail traditionnels
c'est-à-dire qu'il ne s'agit pas
majoritairement loin de là puisque c'est
équivalent de personnes en désert
médical de plus 80% de ses patients qui
ont un arrêt de travail par
téléconsultation bénéficie d'un médecin
traitant et ce n'est pas leur médecin
traitant qui leur a donné cette année à
travail de la même façon c'était
souligné par Gabriel Attal tout à
l'heure dans 70% des cas un peu plus ces
arrêts de travail ne sont associés à
aucune prescription remboursée c'est
uniquement 40% des cas dans le cadre des
arrêts de travail prescrits par un
médecin hors téléconsultations en fait
pour aller encore un peu plus loin on
peut constater par exemple que 200
médecins ont réalisé plus de 73 arrêt de
travail chez des personnes qui étaient
non issues de leurs clientèle il y a
donc une dérive très nette de ces arrêts
de travail qui sont prescrits par
téléconsultation en dehors du médecin
traitant un reportage récent d'ailleurs
au niveau des informations puis vous
montrer cette dérive c'est pourquoi il
semble licite de le faire je rappelle
que ce pour les patients qui ont un
médecin traitant bien entendu il peut
faire un travail particulier
consultations la même chose pour un
médecin qui aurait vu le patient dans
les 12 mois précédents et cas
particulier qui pourrait être des cas de
désert médical très spécifiques pour
être étudié bien entendu au cas par cas
chers confrères vous parlez bien sûr de
mettre en avant la qualité et je ne peux
être que de cet avis bien entendu la
qualité et l'efficience d'ailleurs la
maîtrise médicalisée des dépenses de
santé continuent à présenter une part
importante des économies dans ce dans ce
PLFSS la recherche des concerts dans la
prévention c'est justement l'objectif de
ces consultations de prévention de ces
rendez-vous de prévention sachant comme
je l'ai dit que la stratégie doit être
maximale une stratégie de aller vers
parce que ce qui est important c'est
d'aller justement chercher ces personnes
qui échappent aujourd'hui à ces
consultations s'appuyer également sur
le tissu médico-social dans cette
stratégie d'aller vers et de faire comme
ça a été dit tout à l'heure une campagne
d'information
je pense que j'irai répondu sur la
problématique du transfert de tâches de
la bureaucratie sur les frais dédiés à
la
au covid 19 bien malin et celui qui
aujourd'hui peut dire quels sont les
coûts de la pandémie de covid-19 demain
un milliard et demi de côté pour
l'instant nous suivrons bien entendu
cela de très près comme vous l'imaginez
monsieur Vigier vous m'avez interpellé
sur les padues entre autres
2400 médecins sont actuellement dans
cette situation un effort effet très
spécifiquement et nous avons saisi
l'ordre pour que ces situations soient
réglées le plus vite possible concernant
les autres médecins ils sont dans un
cadre maintenant qui est très structuré
avec l'examen de validation des
connaissances et puis la réalisation ou
non d'un stage tout de suite derrière
bien entendu nous sommes ouverts à
toutes proposition concernant des des
avancées dans ce domaine alors plusieurs
questions ont porté sur l'inflation et
l'ONDAM
alors nous ne faisons pas d'économie sur
l'hôpital je voulais déjà dit nous avons
concerté avec le secteur pour évaluer
les charges supplémentaires auxquelles
il a fait face et
identifier l'impact réel de l'inflation
l'effet de l'inflation
est supérieur pour nos hôpitaux bien
entendu par rapport aux années
précédentes
si on regarde par rapport à 2017 je
rapporte à 2017 l'ONDAM était plutôt de
l'ordre de 2% à 2,2,3 2,1 les années
précédentes c'est 55 57 pardon milliards
d'euros de plus qui sont mis un
investissement important dans notre dans
notre hôpital public l'effort quand même
sur la dame se traduit en 2022 à 800
millions d'euros dans le cadre de cette
prise en charge de l'inflation
pour 2023 nous avons projeté exactement
la même méthode sur l'inflation pour
cette ondame qui donc tient compte des
chocs externes liés à l'inflation et à
l'augmentation du point d'indice
alors pourquoi nous n'avons-nous pas
fait des dialogues de Ségur par rapport
au dialogue de merci c'est justement
grâce à la loi organique votée par
Thomas meignet qui nous permet justement
de pouvoir échanger maintenant sur
l'ensemble de ces sujets avant que nous
puissions en débattre au Parlement et
vous savez que je suis bien sûr ouvert
toujours pour pour en discuter le CNR
santé va apporter de la cohérence
pourquoi apporter de la cohérence parce
que les problématiques se font au niveau
des territoires elles sont pas toutes
les mêmes partout vous l'avez dit les
uns et les autres et c'est bien à
l'échelle des territoires que nous
pourrons régler ces différents problèmes
quant à la question des urgences je
crois que j'ai déjà répondu par rapport
aux effets de la mission Flash
monsieur meunier alors par rapport à la
question de
l'intérim alors la question de l'intérim
médical
pardon rapidement donc la question de
l'intérim médical est paramédical en
début de carrière le coût annuel pour
l'intérim médical était de 500 millions
d'euros en 2013 il est de 1,4 milliards
en 2018 il continue à augmenter
présentant jusqu'à 20% des effectifs de
nos hôpitaux
c'est intérim bien sûr lutter contre cet
intérim c'est un éviter que des jeunes
diplômés s'engagent tout de suite dans
la terrible et nous aurons à discuter de
ce délai essentiellement parce que
l'intérim est un exercice médical qui
est plus difficile puisque on se trouve
ponctuellement dans des situations et
dans un univers que l'on ne connaît pas
et nous aurons également à mettre
rapidement en application début d'année
prochaine le décret concernant la
limitation financière de l'intérim qui
est posée dans la loi dite loi risque
sur la quatrième année je cite je ferai
peut-être un peu une pause après pour
vous donner que la parole je reprendrai
sur la quatrième année de médecine
générale il faut être très clair par
rapport à tout ce que j'ai entendu sur
cette 4e année du DS de médecine
générale c'est une année qui est
demandée par les professionnels de santé
qui considèrent qu'en 3 ans ils n'ont
pas un niveau de formation satisfaisant
en particulier sur des formations comme
la pédiatrie la gynécologie obstétrique
et il souhaite également avoir une
formation spécifique de chefs
d'entreprise afin de pouvoir gérer
correctement un cabinet médical on
constate d'ailleurs que les jeunes
internes de médecine générale quand ils
terminent leur troisième année
s'installe extrêmement peu préfère en
faire une ou deux années de remplacement
enfin justement de se familiariser avec
cette cette gestion d'un cabinet médical
cette quatrième année sera faite en bien
sûr autonomie supervisée elle se fera en
ambulatoire et pas au niveau d'un
hôpital elle se préférentiellement dans
des zones de désert médical la mission
que nous avons lancé avec la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
doit rendre ses conclusions pour la fin
de l'année sur ces différentes modalités
de prise en compte en particulier sur
les modalités de financement de cette 4e
année pour ceux qui seraient dans des
zones des airs médicales
l'appréhension je ne reviens pas dernier
point et puis ensuite je passe la parole
sur le cannabis thérapeutique les
résultats de l'expérimentation sont
insuffisants en termes de patients
inclus pour l'instant donc nous allons
prolonger cette expérimentation pour
avoir des résultats qui soient solides
pour pouvoir discuter correctement de la
prolongation ou pas ou de l'ouverture ou
pas du cannabis thérapeutique voilà je
fais une petite pause merci bien
monsieur le ministre façon vous aurez
l'occasion de revenir puisque les
députés vont reprendre la parole je
passe tout de suite la parole à Monsieur
Jean-Christophe combe
merci merci madame la Présidente alors
je vais essayer de
répondre en regroupant un certain nombre
de questions ça ne vous étonnera pas je
n'ai pas le même regard que certaines et
certains d'entre vous sur sur le texte
qui pour moi pour le gouvernement est un
texte ambitieux dans un contexte de
finance publique contrainte
avec un nom d'âme à 3 qui augmente de
3,7% l'objectif général de dépenses pour
ce qui concerne le médico-social
augmente respectivement de 5,2% pour ce
qui concerne les personnes âgées et de
5,1 pour les personnes en situation de
handicap soit une augmentation de près
d'un milliard et demi d'euros 700
millions pour les personnes
handicapées et 800 millions pour les
personnes âgées donc on peut dire que il
y a quand même une certaine ambition
derrière ce projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale qui est traduit
au travers de des mesures que j'ai
décrites tout à l'heure à la fois sur le
en ce qui concerne les personnes âgées
sur le le renforcement et la continuité
du virage domiciliaire et la
transformation des EHPAD vous l'avez dit
Monsieur Guedj 3000 postes vont être
ouverts dans les EHPAD pour des
soignants vous avez souligné et vous
avez raison la difficulté de recrutement
que nous avons aujourd'hui le manque
d'attractivité aussi de nos formations
initiales mais malgré ces difficultés et
malgré l'ampleur des nombres de postes
qui sont aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas
pourvus aujourd'hui dans ces EHPAD nous
affichons un le volontarisme d'ouvrir
ces 3000 postes et d'enclencher ainsi la
perspective des 50 000 postes en EHPAD
ça représentera 6 à 7 postes
supplémentaires par EHPAD d'ici à la fin
du du quinquennat donc on lance et on
ouvre franchement
cette perspective
sur sur la loi grand âge je l'ai dit et
je le redis je préfère qu'on parle du
contenu avant de parler du contenant de
ce totem qui est la loi grand âge n'est
jamais dit que il n'y aurait pas de loi
grand âge simplement dit qu'il fallait
que on en discute préalablement et
j'observe qu'il y a une toute petite
contradiction dans le fait aujourd'hui
de nous reprocher de vouloir concerter
et de porter ce débat dans le débat
public j'entends que vous auriez préféré
qu'on inscrive d'ores et déjà toutes les
mesures que vous proposez dans la loi
sans aucune concertation pourquoi une
une pourquoi une concertation mais je
vous réponds je vais vous répondre
pourquoi une concertation
parce que tous ces rapports qui sont
pour la plupart d'entre eux excellents
et dont qui font d'ailleurs l'objet de
consensus dont un certain nombre de
mesures ont d'ores et déjà été inscrites
dans la loi le avec
notamment le PLFSS 2022 celui-ci
permettent de voilà de mettre en oeuvre
ces mesures simplement notre ambition
elle est un peu différente c'est à dire
que ces rapports ils ont été
concrètement rédigés par des
professionnels du secteur avec une
vision je pense du grand âge et du Bien
Vieillir très médico-social l'ambition
aujourd'hui qui est portée par le
Président de la République en mettant ce
débat au sein du Conseil national de la
refondation c'est de porter ce débat
auprès de nos concitoyens le sujet
aujourd'hui du Bien vieillir c'est
d'abord un sujet sociétal on veut parler
de prévention on veut parler de
citoyenneté on veut parler de lien
social on veut évidemment parler des
métiers mais c'est d'abord un sujet de
société c'est le regard que porte
aujourd'hui la société sur le
vieillissement et la place que laisse la
société aux personnes âgées et ça ne se
résoudra pas que en mesure PLFSS ou en
inscription de mesure dans la loi il
faut que ça soit porté au bon niveau et
de façon interministérielle
voilà et donc c'est notre ambition qui
est affichée derrière ce grand débat
qu'on veut organiser qu'on veut
relativement court puisque l'objectif
c'est d'aboutir à une stratégie à poser
une ambition et à planifier sa mise en
œuvre des le printemps
2023 concernant les attractivité des
métiers le débat n'est pas épuisé je
vois bien que voilà le débat continue de
de monter dans le cadre des suites du
Ségur je rappelle que pour ce qui
concerne le secteur médico-social c'est
3,2 milliards d'euros d'efforts en année
pleine qui ont été consentis que je
viens d'annoncer nous venons d'annoncer
avec François Brown l'extension de
l'augmentation de la valeur du point de
la fonction publique pour le secteur non
lucratif donc là aussi un effort qui va
concerner l'ensemble des salariés et
comporte avec avec les départements et
que non seulement l'attractivité reste
une priorité ça sera travailler de façon
interministérielle mais des discussions
salariales continuent également dans un
certain nombre de de filières et je
pense notamment à l'ouverture de
négociation salariale dans le domaine de
la petite enfance donc on essaye de
l'oublier personne simplement ce que
j'ai dit et je le redis devant la
représentation nationale aujourd'hui il
faut que chacun dans ce débat prenne ses
responsabilités il faut que on puisse
ouvrir des négociations avec les
départements il faut qu'on puisse ouvrir
des négociations avec les employeurs et
que ceux-ci prennent également leur
responsabilité concernant les deux
questions plus précises qui m'ont été
posées l'une par Madame la Députée riste
concernant les médecins coordonnateurs
un certain nombre ils ont effectivement
bénéficié d'un certain nombre de
d'évolution ou d'assouplissement
concernant le rôle durant la crise
sanitaire notamment pendant la période
vaccinale
vous savez que le rapport chandelle et
Guérin leur
consacre également un certain nombre de
de de réflexion et donc suite à ce
rapport nous faisons expertiser cette
situation et on va voir si la lieu de
faire évoluer le rôle des médecins
coordonnateurs et d'en faire d'une façon
ou d'une autre les médecins traitant des
résidents des EHPAD et puis la deuxième
question technique concernait le la
réforme du complément mode de garde et
la question du plafond horaires
et du financement notamment des des cas
dit atypiques
à proprement parler dans la réforme
pardon ce Christophe Le à proprement
parler dans la réforme le la majorité la
majoration a été supprimée en tant que
tel néanmoins il va nous appartenir dans
le cadre de
l'écriture du décret d'y prêter
attention je vous confirme évidemment
que nous maint la majoration notamment
qui concerne l'accompagnement des
enfants en situation de handicap
très bien merci monsieur le ministre je
passe la parole à présent à Monsieur
Gabriel Attal ouais je vais vraiment
très très vite sur deux points madame
Fiat comme vous et on est vraiment
d'accord sur ce point-là je crois que
nos buralistes sont des commerçants de
proximité absolument essentiels à la
vitalité de nos territoires mais j'en
tire pas les mêmes conclusions que vous
vous sembliez indiqué que la mesure de
santé publique qui a été annoncée et qui
est porté par mon collègue François
Braun qui a parlé d'un relèvement du
prix de 50 centimes et une mise en
danger de nos buralistes et donc est
mauvaise de ce point de vue là
moi je suis pas d'accord avec ça je suis
pas d'accord avec ça parce que la
réalité c'est que la trajectoire tabac
qui a eu lieu dans le dernier
quinquennat à et François Braun l'a
rappelé permis à 2 millions de Français
d'arrêter de fumer
je suis pas d'accord avec ça parce que
je rejette l'idée que les finances
publiques gagneraient de l'argent avec
le tabac ça n'est pas vrai les taxes sur
le tabac rapportent 14 milliards par an
on dépense deux fois plus en coût direct
du tabac notamment pour les cancers on
dépense deux fois plus que ce que le
tabac rapporte pour le tabac
et d'ailleurs il y en a un qui avait
manifestement compris cela il proposait
d'aller très très loin lui c'est
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui proposait le
paquet à 20 euros donc si vous
considérez que avec cette mesure on met
en danger les buralistes vous deviez
considérer que c'était le cas aussi avec
la proposition de Monsieur Mélangeon
l'important l'important c'est quoi
l'important c'est qu'on accompagne les
buralistes pour la diversification de
leurs ressources c'est ce qu'on a fait
depuis 5 ans moi je veux rappeler
380 millions d'euros qui ont été
investis pour aider les buralistes à la
transformation et à la diversification
de leurs ressources on a développé
énormément de services le paiement des
factures du quotidien chez les
buralistes il y en a eu deux millions
l'année dernière le paiement des amendes
avec un accord avec la DG FIP chez les
buralistes c'est aussi une source de
revenus supplémentaires il y a eu 100
millions d'euros d'aide à la
transformation des bureaux de tabac et
je suis actuellement en train de
discuter avec les représentants des
buralistes un nouveau protocole
d'accompagnement pour les années à venir
donc je vais vous rassurer sur ce point
évidemment qu'on faudra accompagner des
buralistes parce qu'on en a besoin
partout sur notre territoire et c'est
l'enjeu des discussions que nous avons
avec eux en ce moment deuxième chose sur
laquelle je voulais revenir vous êtes
fait parler des cotisations sociales en
indiquant que c'était important qu'on
puisse continuer à percevoir des
cotisations sociales pour financer notre
modèle social j'y vois je suis un peu
surpris un vibrant plaidoyer pour notre
action en faveur de l'emploi et de
l'activité économique madame Fiat on
perçoit cette année 17 milliards de
cotisations en plus pour financer notre
modèle social on n'a jamais autant perçu
de cotisations dans notre pays grâce à
quoi mais grâce à la politique
volontariste qu'on a menée pour baisser
la fiscalité sur les entreprises baisser
les impôts sur les entreprises investir
dans la formation des Français parce
qu'on est en train de faire la
démonstration que quand on baisse les
impôts sur les entreprises on perçoit
plus d'impôts des entreprises et oui on
a passé l'impôt sur les sociétés de 33%
à 25%, on perçoit aujourd'hui plus
d'impôts sur les sociétés avec un taux à
25 avec un taux à 33 parce que la
réalité c'est que quand plus accès moins
un gâteau qui grossit vous percevez plus
que quand vous taxez plus un gâteau qui
serait précis dans votre modèle on
assommerait tout le monde de taxes il y
aurait plus grand monde à taxer et donc
plus beaucoup de ressources pour la
sécurité sociale c'est donc je pense
notre ligne qui est la mieux à même à
être suivi enfin sur la question des
retraites à écouter certains on a
l'impression que vous auriez aimé qu'il
y ait la réforme des retraites dans le
texte initial bah si parce que vous
rejetez le fait qu'il y a en ce moment
un travail à une réflexion autour
possiblement d'un amendement pardon de
concerter pardon d'avoir concerté les
présidents de groupe comme l'a fait la
première ministre la semaine dernière
pardon d'échanger avec les organisations
syndicales et les partenaires sociaux
vous pouvez pas d'un côté appeler à
davantage de concertation davantage de
travail avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes et regretter le fait qu'on
annonce pas avant même d'avoir mené
cette concertation une solution dans un
texte initial voilà c'est notre méthode
enfin
enfin je termine pour dire que oui nous
avons s'il vous plaît je termine pour
dire que nous avons eu oui un travail
extrêmement fructueux et je vous
remercie de l'avoir souligné autour des
dialogues de Bercy au départ une partie
importante des oppositions qui disait on
viendra pas tout le monde est venu
ensuite il y a une partie importante des
oppositions qui ont dit on viendra la
première réunion mais comme c'est que de
la com on viendra pas au suivant tout le
monde est venu à toutes les réunions et
tout le monde a dit à la fin que ça
avait été utile tout le monde quel que
soit les partis politiques en disant
qu'on leur avait transmis des
informations utiles en amont qu'on avait
pu travailler ensemble en amont moi je
dis je suis très heureux de voir que
tous les groupes plébiscitent cette
méthode comme la rappeler François Bro
de la nouvelle loi organique fait que
vous avez plus de temps pour travailler
sur le PLFSS cette année mais si à
partir de l'an prochain on peut étendre
le format dialogue de Bercy au PLFSS je
serai le premier évidemment à soutenir
cette idée là